this is a production of Cornell
University
the last year or so in New York there's
been some you know Buzz about seed
treatments so we asked Janine to come
talk today uh Janine has been with the
New York State pesticide uh product
registration program for over 30 years
and has handled all types of pesticide
registration activities so she is here
today to talk to us about neonectinoids
and the future of seed treatments in New
York so Janine
hello everyone
um so I I do have quite a few slides I'm
going to go through this
um kind of fast but um there's a lot of
things that we really have to discuss as
to what's going on with seed treatments
in New York state okay so just briefly
um what neonicotinoids are it's a class
of insecticides uh chemically related to
nicotine it includes acetamaprid
clothing
Imidacloprid and thymethoxone and
they're especially effective against
sucking and chewing insects such as
aphids white flies and there's also bed
bugs and fleas it's a big pet products
too for
um imidacoprid and dinotefurin
okay sure
um it's also used in a range of
different products
um indoor insect control is Big AG
greenhouse and of course there's the
seed treatments
so many of these active ingredients are
registered with various use restrictions
with which limit the outdoor exposure
for example is limited to crack and
crevice or spot treatments and there's
some sln registrations that have been
allowed for limited use mainly for
direct application to like tree trunks
for invasive species
clothianodin is registered for indoor
use only and Seed treatment products are
not registered in New York state
so the way it works for the pesticide
registration are all products have to be
registered in order to be sold or for
sale distributed or used in the state
the application of the seed treatment
pesticide product to the seeds is
considered the use so for clothing you
cannot do that in New York state however
as long as the seeds are treated by
pesticide products that are legally
registered in whatever state they're
being applied in they can be shipped
into New York State and planted
so that brings us to the legislation
um there seems to be concern that we are
not regulating those
seed treatments because for example
clothing can be used for seed treatments
but we specifically did not register it
so there's proposed legislation
has been referred to as the birds and
bees protection act this year it did
pass the assembly and the Senate and
almost made it through the Senate but we
do expect it to come back next year and
it would add a section to the ecl the
Environmental Conservation law under
article 33
title 13 unlawful Acts
so the proposed language of the
legislation would make it unlawful for
any person to sell offer for sale or
distribute any corn soybean or wheat
seeds coated or treated with pesticides
containing lothianidine and medical
oprid thymethoxin
dynatipherion or acetamaprid
and the proposed legislation had a date
of January 1st of 2025 but since it
didn't get approved that date would
change when they
do the new legislation
so um in order to allow users only
specific provisions and I'm not going to
read all through this but uh so it would
only be under
uh direct consultation with DEC and
again markets uh and they have to issue
a executive order determining that
there's a lack of commercially available
untreated seeds or that compliance would
result in undue hardship
and then it would they would do a
temporary suspension of the prohibition
and you'd have to specify the time frame
and the type of seed and it'd be a very
limited time frame
there's also additional provisions and
it's going after no person shall apply
or treat outdoor ornamental plans and
turf except for the production of an
agricultural commodity and that is for
immuno corporate thymothaxon or
acetamaprid on or after July 1st of 2024
and again since this didn't go through
that date will be changed when they do
propose new legislation and we assume
that they're going to have say some type
of the same Provisions in the next
go-around
they also had in there that the active
ingredients cloth theanidine and
dinotapherin would be effective
immediately
and they do have some exceptions for
environmental emergency and then again
our department would have to consult
with Agate markets and determine justify
with a detailed order that there's a
valid environmental emergency the
pesticide would be effective in
addressing the environmental emergency
and no other product can be used so
they're trying they're very it's very
limited they're trying to really cut
down on the use of the neonics
so this they're limiting it with um very
like I said it's it would only be six
months so it's not like you know yeah
we're going to allow this yeah we say
there's an emergency but it's only gonna
be for six months so it's really they're
tightening the Noose on the neonics
they do have an environmental emergency
definition in the legislation and um you
know it's right up there but so it's
very specific
um and you and in order to do the
emergency declaration we would have to
be very specific and it would have to be
it would be an official thing with our
department in egg and markets
so why are they doing this there's a big
desire to prohibit the use of neonic
treated seeds and certain neonic
products used for non-egg purposes
others various reports regarding the
limited benefits of using treated seeds
versus the risks to pollinators they're
saying that the the wrist pollinators
outweighs the the benefits
the seed treatment pesticide products
are registered but as I said before the
the pesticide treated seeds are not
registered and we don't we as in the
Department of Environmental Conservation
do not regulate treated seed so there's
nrdc and other groups who want treated
seeds to be regulated as pesticide
products
and you know there's various concerns
um there's lots of reports and and so on
about the use of of
um neonics and you know what they do to
to you know surface waters and
pollinators and so on so we are being
urged to do more things to protect
pollinators uh the issue is very complex
and there are very many factors which
impact pollinator health I mean there's
you know genetic diversity there's you
know monocultures and so on and there's
also you know the varroa mites and so on
with bees and pesticides I mean
sure there's pesticides too
but pesticides are very easy targets
they're already very heavily regulated
and the neonic treated seeds are
considered a loophole
so in April of 2017 a group of
beekeepers and farmers and ngos at nrdc
uh submitted a petition to EPA and they
requested that EPA amend or formally
reinterpret the treated article
exemption so that it does not apply to
treated seeds they also asked EPA to
declare that pesticide treated seed is
subject to regulation under fifra as a
pesticide and this is huge this is
absolutely huge
so just I I just this is the treated
article definition
uh so when I think of a treated article
I think of a shower curtain
um they they treat the um you know
shower curtain so it doesn't get mold
and mildew on it
um there's also like telephone poles are
treated but you don't register a
telephone pole you register what it was
used to treat the pole
um just like shopping carts you know you
see all the um
all the micro band stuff that's that's
considered a treated article
so the petition claimed that EPA did not
adequately assess the risks from the use
of seeds of the seed treatment
pesticides that have systemic properties
and the use of seeds themselves that
have been treated with the pesticides so
there's a concern that the use of the
treated seeds are causing a problem
because they should you don't know what
that is doing to the environment just
using that treated seed
and they also claim that the treated
article exemption may not cover treated
seed without an adequate assessment of
the risks
so EPA did respond the end of September
they did not agree with the petition as
to the treated article exemption and
they will not Grant the petition request
to either you know reinterpret or amend
their regulatory text for the exemption
to exclude uh seed treated with systemic
pesticides
but EPA did agree with the petitioner's
concerns on clearly communicating the
labeling instructions to the users of
the treating pesticide and the treated
seed so as you were saying before they
were going after the labeling for
treated seeds this kind of goes along
with that that there's concerns that
there's a big gap between the pesticides
that are used to treat the seeds and how
the the label on this treated seed is so
they're saying that there's a gap there
and they they want to focus on that
so EPA has been reviewing labeling
instructions for pesticides registered
for seed treatment uses and making sure
that that those instructions are correct
and um there's complete and appropriate
instructions for the distribution sale
and use of both the treating pesticide
and the treating seed so that would be
like the seed tag labeling
also EPA said they intend to issue an
advanced notice of proposed rulemaking
to seek additional information on
whether or or to what extent pesticide
treated seed is being distributed sold
or used in a manner inconsistent with
treating pesticide labeling
so they're trying to figure out if
everybody's doing what they're supposed
to be doing and they're going to
consider appropriate actions if they
find that there's problems
also the more concerning as part of the
advanced notice of proposed rulemaking
EPA will also explore the option of
issuing a rule pursuant to fit for
Section 3A to regulate pesticide treated
seed
to make sure that it's it's uh since
consistent with treating pesticide and
treated seed labeling so this would
change how seeds are regulated
pesticide treated seeds would be
regulated differently than non-treated
seeds I mean if you think about this
it's kind of like Paul I mean I don't
even know how they would do this
um so I mean I've been in this program
for you know over 30 years I always
thought of seeds as an agricultural
commodity
I don't even I don't think of them as a
treated article I just think of them as
separate
so you know they're they're trying to
pull them into some sort of
regulation and they want them regulated
as pesticides
so right now seeds are regularly
regulated by USDA in accordance with the
federal seed act in New York State uh
the department of Ag and markets
regulates seeds in in the state and they
they they would be the ones that would
go out and you know get a package of of
something and test it and make sure
now the proposed legislation that we had
in New York state would add Provisions
to the ecl to regulate seeds but there's
nothing in the Environmental
Conservation law regarding seeds we
don't regulate seeds so I don't know how
we would even do that and I've said that
before it's like how are we going to do
that oh you just do it it's like
well they're not pesticides how are you
going to register them who's going to
register them is it going to be on the
farmer to register them is it going to
be on who's treating them to register
and when you register a pesticide
product now there's labeling involved
somebody has to label the product so
there's a number involved there's
there's all of the registrations that
they have to do they have to send it to
the department they have to pay for it
somebody has to label it there's all
kinds of tracking and chains and so on I
don't even know how that would work I I
quite honestly it's like I have no idea
how they're going to do this
and as I said the latest EPA proposal is
going to explore options on how to
regulate treated seed in accordance with
fifra as a pesticide I just don't know
how they're going to do that you're
going to change I mean so you're going
to have non-treated seeds and then
treated seeds and they're going to be
regulated in a different way I just
don't know I mean I don't know how
they're going to work that out
so you know we have many states that are
taking actions against neonics I mean we
have you know Massachusetts Maine
Maryland Wisconsins they're they're
restricting
um neonics and they're banning consumer
use and this is not just seed treatment
products but it's it's it's you know
consumer products uh the thought for
Consumer products is that consumers
aren't as careful and they don't read
the labels as as well as a certified
applicator or someone who is trained so
that's why a lot of times the uh
restrictions go after the consumer
products
and they're they're they think that the
use of these products are more for
Aesthetics and that you really don't
need it you just want a beautiful lawn
or you just want your your beautiful
flowers
um in Connecticut they're doing certain
neonic use patterns
um classifying as restricted use and
they have different guidelines for seed
treatments uh Oregon prohibits the use
of neonics on Linden trees and that had
to do with the um there was a huge uh B
kill somebody sprayed uh a tree I think
it was like in a Target parking lot and
they killed like you know eighty
thousand bumblebees or something it was
really ridiculous so I mean it brought
to the attention that yeah well it's an
insecticide so it's going to kill bees
but they the bees were right there
and Vermont it's very difficult to
figure out exactly what Vermont is doing
but um outdoor use of neonics are
classified as restricted use and they
require the reporting of treated article
seed and quantity of untreated seeds
sold so you know they keep talking about
neonics and Seed treatment but where is
it going to stop is it going to go to
other
neonic products that treat seed I mean
we have tons of fungicides that are used
on on seeds I mean where is it going to
stop who's going to say oh it's only
those and it's not those
it's going to be very difficult to carve
out
so what is New York state doing
um because we have received criticism
for not doing enough regarding the use
of neonics in the state they you know we
get called to just ban it why are you
allowing it it's you don't need it
um the proposed legislation will force
additional Provisions to decrease or
eliminate the use of neonics but that's
not really the way we want to do it we
want it to go back to our pesticide
program
so we decided to one of the easiest
things we can do to show that we're
doing something is to reclassify some of
the neonic products as restricted use
and that goes along with other states at
least it's like well yeah New York state
is doing you know the same thing as you
know Connecticut or whoever
so pesticide products containing
imitiloprid acetamaprid or thymethoxin
that are labeled for foliar or
widespread outdoor use or seed treatment
will be reclassified as restricted use
and that's effective January 1st
of 2023 and we've told the the
registrant Swain Advance about this so
hopefully the
um the news has trickled down so there's
27 imidacloper products and 23
thymethoxin seed treatment products that
will be restricted
so what that means is that in order to
get one of these neonic products to
treat your seeds you either have to be a
commercial applicator or or you know
have a commercial permit to sell it and
so on so but I there's really not that
many that I know of commercial seed
traders in New York state that's what
I've been told
correct me if I'm wrong but um I don't
know the impacts to um
you know people in this room or you know
the siege people who use treated seed in
New York state
um the registrants did not indicate that
it was going to be a huge problem they
didn't really
blink and I actually so I don't know if
they
actually told people about it and don't
know anything or or it's not really that
big of a deal
so neonic products that are labeled for
limited ground application directly to
the base of trees shrubs and plants are
not included in this reclassification so
there are a few products that are not
going to be restricted
so uh Jan I wanted to add this for you
uh so what else we're doing in New York
state is the Department of Ag and
markets is is also looking at seed
treatments because they are the ones
that regulate treated seed and they
recognize that seed treatments are a
valuable tool for the AG industry but
their current Authority only provides
the ability to require labeling
untreated seed if the treatments pose a
threat to human health or other
vertebrates in the quantities used and
that's what how their their regulations
and their laws are written and that's
like Mercury compounds these are very
old laws
so they're thinking about doing
um changing their laws so that it can
enable the AG markets to also label
treated seeds for environmental concerns
uh considering such as water quality and
um off Target organisms like pollinators
so the the thought was maybe having a
supplemental label that you didn't have
to necessarily attach to the container
or bag but say if you have a seed a bag
of seeds with clothing treated seeds you
would have a supplemental label that had
best management practices and so on
about it but this is this was a proposal
last year I don't know they're tweaking
it everything's changing so I don't know
what the new one's going to be next year
um
the Scott menraf my my supervisor was
like well you know it might change I go
well I'm going to say that they're doing
something I don't know exactly if it's
going to be this it's going to be
something else
but the whole goal is to allow
um the department to require some sort
of labeling so that you can kind of keep
it going and you're not going to lose it
so you know best managers practices and
you know getting the word out to the end
users what they're kind of looking for
and our goal as as a state as Regulators
is to be able to maintain the use of
pesticides that are needed for the
critical uses while minimizing the
impacts to human health and the
environmental environment and that
includes the pollinators and other
non-target organisms we have to have
ample tools in the toolbox because
there's always another invasive species
coming up it seems like there's there's
always these weird things coming in you
know we have the you know emerald ash
borers and the Asian longhorn beetles
and there's always a new you know
something or other coming
and we want to avoid resistance you want
to switch from one to another you don't
you don't want to rely on one certain
class or one certain product
so what can we do
um you know we try to respond with sound
science and it's very difficult with the
internet
um
you know we always hear this oh there's
this this study saying that you know
it's killing deer imidacloperate is
killing deer and you're like you know we
showed that study to our ecotoxicologist
he goes that's a really bad study it's
like yeah but trying to get that
information back to you know the people
in the legislature that are looking at
that studying like oh my God it's
killing deer we have to do hurry up and
do something so you know it's very
difficult there's there's a lot of
misinformation out there and trying to
to you know get the right information
out there is very very difficult
and it's very important for them to know
that the amount of pesticide used for
seed treatment is less than using
multiple post plant applications they
don't realize that you know seed
treatments are actually you're using
less
and it also has to do with favorable
planting cultivation techniques
um you know there's there's a lot of
things that you know go in conjunction
with treated seeds
and we also want to highlight and
promote best management practices and
integrated Pest Management because that
is really the way to go you know that's
that is the best way and a lot of times
when I'm talking to some of the you know
people are Executives I said you know
Farmers just aren't throwing pesticides
out willy-nilly I said they're working
on very thin margins you're trying to do
the you know what you can with you know
what you have and try not to spend a lot
you're not trying not to get out in the
field 10 times because that's very
expensive so you know you're trying to
limit you know the resources that you
expend and they're like oh we never
thought of it that way it's like so it's
very difficult trying to get that
information out there
questions
yes
things like that are biological but
you're going to be handling the product
that's already that previous
stuff
that's a good question I mean a lot of
times when we get Biologicals coming in
if it's a pesticide we might know about
it if it's not a pesticide we don't even
know
so you know that might be something that
would have to go on the treated seed
labeling you know you get the the seed
bag say you know if you're this contains
you know whatever if you're handling it
again to put more stuff on it you make
sure you're you're using the correct PPE
and so on
it's a good question I don't I don't
know
a lot of times for the Biologicals for
the bio pesticides
um EPA is is sometimes they think well
it's a bio pesticide it's all right
but we review it and and there's a lot
of lack of data as to you know for Don
targets and and things like that so
there's there's some data gaps for
biopesticides
but I don't know you know further
handling of treated seed to to apply
something else
and not even know how the Biologicals
would work with
you know like insecticides on it they're
going to have some sort of
um
I don't know some combination and do
something I don't know
anybody yes
I correct that the sale of a human unit
you can see to a farmer not for sale
correct
correct
because the the product the bucket The
Jug is the restricted product
so once you apply it to the seed it's no
longer considered a pesticide product
and that's the that's the nut that the
legislature is trying to crack
any other questions yes
regardless
things that we said before when you said
at the beginning that made it sound like
well I believe if you're um like um
a farmer using like if you're just doing
a general pesticide application on your
farm you don't have to be certified but
if you're a commercial seed treater
working we're ever doing the seeds as
your business yeah you would have to be
certified and then using a restricted
product there's other
um things that you have to do there's
the reporting and and so on there's a
whole chain of custody type of thing for
that
but
anybody else
yes
well you know in general if you use
treated seeds then there wouldn't be
needs for you know a lot of other things
I'm sure there's other
products that are used after that but
um in general there would be less
so so that's that's the thing they're
focusing on neonics it's like yeah but
if you get rid of this then you're going
to use you know 10 more of this over
here and that might not be what you want
either
so it's very complicated
well thank you very much
all right thanks Janine again you know
neonics have kind of been the buzzword
the last few years here in New York
um nysaba and the board has definitely
taken their time and gone out to
legislator and talked to them so if
anyone is interested you know please
talk to those who aren't on a nice Ava
board more about this most of us will be
around through lunch and I don't know if
Janine will be around if if you want to
talk a little bit more about it our next
speaker with us again on Zoom here is
Gary monkfold he is a professor of Plant
Pathology at the Iowa State University
SEED Center he is the chair of the ISU
graduate program and see technology and
business and is a co-director for the
administrative unit of the U.S national
seed Health System a collaborative
public and private program whose mission
is to facilitate U.S seed exports to
research method standardization and
accreditation related to phytosanitary
testing and inspection procedures so
with us today he is going to talk about
seed health and harmonizing testing
methods
all right well good morning everybody
I'm happy to have the opportunity to
share with you this morning some of the
work we do here at the Iowa State seed
Science Center and I'll also be talking
about uh some uh other
um
programs that uh have similar goals to
what we do with the national sea Health
System
and I chose the title uh about the
collaboration because I really want to
emphasize how important that is in a
whole Space of seed health and the
particularly with the international
movement of seeds which is so critical
for today's seed industry to operate
even when we're talking about seeds that
are sold domestically it's very likely
that in the course of the development of
those varieties of seeds that they uh
that the international shipment of seeds
was involved so this is something that
really is critical for the the seed
industry to operate the way it does
today and
it really does require collaboration
among a lot of different stakeholders to
make sure that the seeds that we plant
are not responsible for spreading pests
and diseases
there are a lot of stakeholders involved
who uh collaborate in these efforts and
this slide has plenty of acronyms which
I will uh some of which I'll elaborate
on and others well you can follow up
later if you like but we can put these
stakeholders into some different
categories we have the plant protection
organizations which are at the either
the national or Regional level so here
in the United States it's USDA aphis we
have the North American Plant Protection
Organization the European plant
Protection Organization and there are
other Regional organizations around the
globe we also have plant protection
agencies with within the states that are
also participating
uh then there is a another category of
what I would call official national
organizations which are uh
semi-governmental so
the national seed Health System would
fall into that category so that's the
program that we administer here from the
Iowa State seed Science Center and it is
a collaboration between us and USDA
office and the seed industry and you'll
hear a lot more about that as I progress
another example javez is a similar type
of organization in in France and then
now is also an analogous organization in
the Netherlands which also has a global
reach due to the importance of the
benevolence and the global seed industry
and of course the seed industry itself
is a very important collaborator
uh there are a couple specific
organizations you have the international
seed Federation which which operates the
issue program which is the international
seed Health Initiative which focuses
very heavily on vegetable crops and
developing seat Health testing methods
for vegetable crops
the American Seed trade Association I've
already mentioned is a key player in the
National sea Health System but also is
involved in helping the seed industry
with many of the phyto sanitary issues
that pop up on a seemingly daily basis
when it comes to
moving seeds International
and of course around the world there are
other national state industry
associations that are analogous to ask
them and then there are many individual
companies that participate heavily in
developing and validating seed Health
testing methods either Under the
Umbrella of issue or in collaboration
with nshs or in collaboration with other
organizations like like Napa
and then on the international global
scale you have the international
protection convention and the
international seed testing Association
and on the slide here the a few um
uh programs that I've shown in bold are
the ones that I'm planning to talk to
you about in a little bit more detail
today
so there are a lot of challenges when it
comes to CDL testing and the top one I
think we have to agree is the issue of
emerging pathogens
there are a number of examples right now
like the Tomato Brown rugos fruit virus
and possibly viroids and tomatoes and
peppers High planes virus in corn
uh
maze Clorox model virus and other corn
pathogen and these pathogens when they
do emerge they tend to become a
regulatory issue much more quickly than
the scientific Community is able to
adapt to them in terms of being able to
come up with
effective validated testing methods and
and management practices that are
designed to deal with uh pathogens that
we don't have experience with so so
that's a really big Challenge and right
along with that comes the kind of
sanitary regulations which are always
changing some of those changes are in
response to emerging pathogens but
others are in response to other forces
that may or may not have a scientific
basis and those changing regulations are
very difficult again to adapt to on the
fly when we're shipping so many
shipments of seeds internationally
just as an example of that the volume
of international sea shipment continues
to grow in The Atheist annual report
they reported that they
approved 703
000 final sanitary certificates in the
year 2021 that does not include the ones
that may have not been improved because
of problems that were with the
applications
and then you have a capacity issue with
the seat Health testing system in the
labs that are involved when especially
when there are new regulations that
require a great deal of extra testing
it's not that easy to scale up
immediately in the public Labs or even
within the companies to be able to
provide the the throughput necessary for
an increased demand for testing
public facilities as always have limited
resources and those resources are not
elastic in response to emerging issues
that come up for seed testing
and then of course one of the things
that we focus on and try to
um
continuously try to resolve is the lack
of agreement on best testing methods
among trading partners and so that's uh
gets to the harm harmonization issue
which is something that we continue to
work toward but it's always kind of a
two steps forward one step back kind of
procedure and you know there are a lot
of different opinions
and as a sort of a component of that
lack of agreement is this issue about
the biological relevance of testing
results when you test seeds for
pathogens and if you have a positive
result
does that okay what in what's what
extent does that really indicate the
risk of a disease outbreak occurring
when you plant those seeds and this is
becoming more and more uh acute because
of the fact that we have more and more
sensitive testing methods which are
capable of of the tuckling very low
levels of contamination or
components of a pathogen which are
detected in terms of either proteins or
nucleic acids which don't necessarily
tell us that that pathogen is is viable
or able to cause disease
and then on the regulatory side uh we we
know that not all regulations are based
on science so we continue to try to
inject science into the regulatory
systems that we deal with around the
world
just to give you a little bit more
um background on the scope of the
challenge if we look at bacteria for
example uh that are believe that are
that are regulated uh in terms of seed
trade the international seed Federation
has a pest list
that includes 15 vegetable crops or crop
groups and on their list they indicate
that
they have data about 184 bacterial host
combinations that are subject to phyto
sanitary regulations
and of those 184
according to their literature reviews
that they've done only 28 of those have
definite evidence for which seed of the
pathway and then there are 19 additional
ones for which the evidence is equivocal
whether or not seed may be a pathway
but that still leaves well over a
hundred of these bacterial host
combinations where there is no evidence
let's see this pathway and yet they're
still subject to five Centier
regulations
uh the international testing Association
has a list that covers 23 non-vegetable
hosts
and this is um
uh if you can see for one thing in the
non-vegetable crops the numbers of
Seaborn bacteria are lower they they
list
34 back to your host combinations 15 of
which uh seeds there's evidence that
seed is a pathway and 11 of which seed
may or may not be a pathway so this
I guess the take-home message here is
number one vegetable crops have a lot
more problems with bacterial diseases
that are could be seedborn and also
there are many regulations for pathogens
where there is really no evidence for
foresee being a pathway for
establishment of the pathogens
that's just for the bacteria I could
show you similar data for viruses and
fun job and I think that that you get
the idea
okay so uh when we do have emerging
pathogens or changing regulations or
simply have industry needs for new seat
Health tests there are a number of
different organizations that are
involved in developing and validating
these methods and I'll talk in a little
bit more detail about these three
ISTA ISF issue initiative and the
national seat Health System
but there are other organizations that
also develop and validate methods under
ippc or the regional plant protection
organizations or the national plant
protection organizations
but I'll talk a bit more now about about
Vista
um and I guess before I do that uh I
want to kind of bring to your attention
that we do have some I would say
Universal criteria that we try to agree
on among the different organizations in
terms of what constitutes a valid seed
Health testing method and those basic
characteristics include sensitivity
specificity
repeatability reproducibility and
robustness and you can see the
explanations of those things on the
slide
and uh the the level of sensitivity
that's required for sea Health testing
method it varies according to the
pathogen but the important thing is that
it needs to be defined
uh for any seed Health testing method
that's being developed
specificity obviously also is important
and that one is pretty Universal in the
sense that we do want every seed Health
test to be
giving us positive results only when we
have the true pathogen that we're trying
to detect and not give false positives
when we detect something
where you detect something that is is
not the target organism
so these are the criteria that are
um generally used or universally used
although there are subtle differences in
interpretation uh when various groups
will do validation studies
so under ISTA you have the seed health
committee and uh there are two members
from the United States on this committee
including me the seat health committee
under ISTA has an objective to develop
and validate methods but also to do
other things like
organizing proficiency tests so that
accredited Laboratories under ISTA can
demonstrate that they're able to
accurately carry out the methods that
they're accredited to do the CDF
committee also organizes workshops and
other training opportunities
and those develop the reference pass
list that I talked about a couple slides
ago
and so if you look at the ISTA website
there's a there's this video which I'm
not going to show you here that
summarizes what the seat health
committee does and you can learn more
about the proficiency testing and the
method validation and other Technologies
related to
um student or microorganisms on the
website
so generally uh sort of a thumbnail
sketch of how the seat health committee
Works uh methods are either developed
internally by committee members or
externally the process involves
proposing a comparative test plan which
is then
approved and organized by the seat
health committee
then and those participants and the
comparative test will be Labs that may
or maybe internally external to the seed
health committee mostly their ISTA
accredited Labs but not necessarily
always
and after the comparative test is done
the report is submitted to the Sea
health committee and we vote on whether
to accept those results and then if
those are approved they're passed on to
the instant general assembly for their
for their approval and then they will
appear that method will appear on the
list of a list of methods on the website
and the procedures described in this
document that I took a screenshot of
over there on the right of the slide
so the this is a screenshot of the the
website that um
where the methods are listed and there
are currently 32 host pathogen
combinations with methods that are on
the insta website
some of those have more than one
alternative and then there's a link that
you can see here also for the test list
one thing I'll comment on is that there
are 32 methods on this page and you can
judge from
so in my previous slides that there are
many many more uh Seaborn pathogens than
just 32 and so there's a continuous need
for new methods because there are many
pathogens from which we don't have
methods that have been validated and
approved by by ISTA or or other
organizations
another program that I already mentioned
is the international seed Health
Initiative which is Under the
Umbrella of the international seed
Federation
and so this is a bit of information
there from their website but uh
generally speaking this is an industry
Group which also has the objective of
developing and validating seat Health
testing methods that are agreed upon uh
not only among industry participants but
those methods are promoted to be used
for phytosanitary certification
and currently the the issue vegetable
group has methods for 33 pathogens 12 of
those are also ISTA methods and they
also have the test list that I mentioned
before which covers mostly or entirely
covers vegetable crops so again you can
see that the number is not hot that high
in terms of all the methods that are out
there and there is a significant overlap
between the instant and issue veg
methods but they uh they are uh they're
also a number of methods that appear uh
on one
under one program but not the other
and then the next program that I'll talk
about that I'm involved with a lot more
heavily is the national seat health
system as I mentioned uh it's a
collaboration between
aphis Asta Iowa State University and the
state agents at the state Departments of
AG
it's been around since 2001. you can see
the order chart there on the right the
administrative unit that is shown in the
middle of the org chart is the ISU seed
Science Center
it's Guided by a policies and procedures
board and answers to the accreditation
manager at usdaafis which is Sarita
Maggie
the policies and procedures board is
populated
[Music]
by
representatives from American Seed trade
Association but also other
organizations that are involved in seed
testing as well as the national plant
board which consists of the state
Department's AG
and Charlie block and I are the
co-directors of the administration unit
so here are the objectives for nshs like
you know the main one that I'm talking
about today is
developing standardized seat Health
testing uh uh for laboratory and
phytosanitary inspection
we accredit labs to carry out those
inspections and testing those labs or
entities
can be public or private
organizations many of them are seed
companies others are proper Improvement
associations and to say a little bit
more about that in the next couple
slides
so we have on our website the methods
for 72 host package and combinations and
we do to the extent that we can
harmonize those with both ISTA and issue
so many of the methods on our website
are Vista and or issue methods but we
also have additional ones that that they
have not validated
we do offer accreditation not only for
seed Health testing in the lab but also
for field inspection in the field of
greenhouse sampling for phytosanitary
testing and visual inspection for for
phyto sanitary certification which is an
option that is
um that is viable for in in some
countries for some some Commodities
um in lieu of uh field inspection or lab
CPAP testing
so those are the accreditation options
uh we have 26 organizations accredited
10 of those are private testing Labs or
Inspection Services
10 seed companies for crop Improvement
associations and two public seed testing
Labs including the laboratory here at
Iowa State
uh we have 12 accredited for sampling
four for visual inspections six for
field inspection and 13 for laboratory
seat Health testing
that's kind of the breakdown of the
accreditations
and uh it's uh
it affects the the whole range of states
in in the U.S we do have a heavy
concentration of accreditation on the on
the Midwest and the West Coast uh the
West Coast emphasis has a lot to do with
the vegetable seed industry presence
there and then in the midwest it's
heavily waded toward corn and soybean
inspections and testing as you might
imagine
this is just to indicate the the detail
to which we have procedures uh described
for doing validation for seed Health
testing methods
um The Matrix over there on the right
lists those criteria that I talked about
before in terms of sensitivity
specificity
Etc
and in The Matrix we list the
the definitions of those criteria and
also the expectations for evidence that
we expect the
um the validation studies to include in
order to demonstrate those criteria than
that we have a an ad hoc peer review
system for the validation reports that
come in
and then we evaluate those here at the
administration unit and then they are
presented our recommendations are
presented to the policies and procedures
board who then vote on whether to accept
results
we have a couple projects underway right
now one is for Stewart's corn and one is
for bacteria blight and soybean and we
have new new projects that are are
coming up continuously
uh one last thing I'd like to talk about
that is an offshoot of the natural seed
health system is the seat Health
dashboard I like to talk about this
again is a very
um
successful example of a public-private
collaboration to protect seed Health
this one specifically targets acute
Kermit crop seeds that are being
imported into the United States where
most of our efforts are directed toward
testing seeds that will be exported
so the seed Health dashboard you may
have heard of a program
prior to this that was called nshap that
was the predecessor to the C Health
dashboard
and at the bottom of the slide we have
the running totals there under this
program uh we have
we have collected results on almost 60
000 imported cucurbancy Lots from 34
different countries and uh 99.6 percent
of those seat Lots were clean for cgmob
0.4 percent
that tested positive are either
destroyed or re-exported back to the
country of origin so this has been I
think a an excellent voluntary
collaboration you know seed companies uh
to protect everybody's best interests in
terms of keeping CGM and B out of the
United States
where it has been introduced more than
once but it's under eradication and we
are really trying to keep it from being
re-introduced
a couple uh words about refresh I don't
really have time to explain this program
but this is a
um the regulatory framework for seed
Health which is a new approach to
regular to regulating seed born
pathogens that that's being developed by
aphis it's a systems approach that will
take into account all the management
practices that are involved in reducing
the risk of having contaminated seeds so
again this will be a voluntary
accreditation program I really just
wanted to point out that that seat
Health testing will definitely still be
part of this program uh even if one of
the objectives of refresh is to move
away from testing every single
Consignment of siege that are that are
shipped internationally but there
definitely will be
CDL testing at critical control points
along the seed production and
distribution pipeline
so if you have questions about that I
can get into that a little bit more but
um
I just want to point out that CDL
testing is is here to stay
um
and just to wrap things up uh I think I
hope I've made the point that seat belt
testing is and will continue to be a
crucial component of the global seed
system uh and there are a lot of
Dynamics going on so that the needs are
constantly changing and we really need
everybody working together in order to
adapt to the new challenges and the
changing needs for seat Health testing
and uh
there is this move towards what is
referred to as systems approaches like
refresh which uh really seek to
um
take advantage or leverage all the
quality management practices that are
being done within the seed industry uh
including seat out testing but much
broader than just you know testing that
all work together to reduce the risk of
having plutonium seeds ship
internationally
uh we'll make one little pitch here for
uh our graduate program if you want to
learn more about this and other aspects
of seed technology and and the seed
industry business practices we have
graduate program and C technology and
business that I chair and it's 100
online program which really is geared
toward seed industry
professionals who are looking to advance
their careers and you can contact Laura
youngberg here at the email address or
go to our website which is seedgrad at
cgrad.iastate.edu
and with that a few
acknowledgments I mentioned Charlie
block and Sarika Nagy Kelly Iverson is
the national seat Health System Program
Coordinator
and there are several other people here
who have helped me with the presentation
so
I'll stop there I've used up my time and
if there's a time for any questions I'd
be glad to try to answer those
Gary thank you very much for your
presentation
covered a lot of information but really
really good overview of advocacy now
thank you so much
okay well it's been a pleasure and I
hope you guys enjoy the rest of your
conference
again thank you Gary
um we're going to transition a little
bit here with our next speaker Virginia
Moore she is a faculty member at Cornell
in the plant breeding and genetics
in her lab she works on a range of
species including forages cover crops
and perennial grains focused on breeding
for sustainable cropping systems so
Jenny is going to talk to us today about
cover crop breeding for the northern U.S
so please welcome Ginny we need this
switched over
okay great well sorry I I can't join in
person today I just got out of teaching
my last class of the semester and
couldn't make it up quite in time but
glad to be able to join virtually and
um and share about this this topic
um
so
um as as I was just mentioned I I work
on on cover crops among other species
and uh specifically focused on reading
for New York State and other Northern
regions in the U.S and I probably don't
need to tell you all of the benefits of
of cover crops I think this group
is likely familiar
um you know we we know that that people
have been planting cover crops for a
long time for all of these ecosystem
service
um and and farm management benefits
hearing I imagine more about cover crops
uh on the the policy side lately there's
been a new new incentive programs that
have been passed and both at federal and
state levels and private sector
organizations as well that are that are
incentivizing farmers to plant more
cover crops and and I think they're an
especially Salient management practice
um you know with
um kind of environmental excuse me
environmental crises that that are
ongoing and and in a lot of cases
accelerating and you know this
um
photo in the lower right corner looks
like it could be something out of the
1930s but this is a 2022 image of
um you know dust storms in
South Dakota and Minnesota
um and this year
um and and we know that cover crops can
help with with a lot of these these
major environmental environmental
challenges that we're facing
um cover crop adoption
uh in the U.S has uh has been increasing
so so these data are from the 2017 uh
census of Agriculture by the USDA
um we're in the process of doing the
2022 census now so these numbers will be
updated and I'll be really curious to
see how what kind of change we've seen
over the last five years
um but but in 2017 we had 15.4 million
Acres of cover crops planted which
represented a 50 increase since the
previous agences
um but that's still a drop in the bucket
but it's only less than four percent of
total cropland Acres
um so so progress is is happening and
and it feels quick right now but they're
still a long way uh to go to to adopt
this this practice that that is an
important tool to mitigate some of these
environmental challenges in agriculture
and
uh
as as farmers are are beginning to adopt
cover crops on a larger scale we see
that
um that there's more infrastructure
that's being developed
um to help farmers figure out how to
make decisions that cover cropping is a
a fairly knowledge intensive practice
and Farmers often struggle to to figure
out what species they should be planting
at what time of year at what seeding
rate
um
and and many other other kind of
question marks for them and and
um this kind of infrastructure
uh exists for other crops
um at a much larger scale and we're just
now sort of developing these tools to
help farmers make decisions in this
cover crop space and there's there's a
huge amount of effort right now
um
among researchers and extensionists and
other cover cropping professionals to to
build these tools and and to help
farmers make good decisions about cover
crops and use them more effectively on
their Farms
um the the regional cover crop councils
uh have been a big push on this front
and nrcs as well
um
and
uh and so farmers are increasingly
um you know able to make better
decisions about species and and seeding
rates and and timing and
um planting timing and termination
timing all these these major decisions
which is huge uh but uh could have a big
gap that Still Remains is is variety
information
um so so cover crop
uh
selections are are typically made at a
species level and
um and farmers are often planting
variety not stated material or
um or or some variety that may or may
not be adapted to their region and they
often don't have a lot of choices
um depending on the species that they're
planting
um and
uh we saw in a this survey that was
conducted by by Matt Ryan and some other
collaborators of mine around 2015.
um who did a survey of organic and
conventional Farmers about their their
perspectives on cover crop use and and
particularly about the need for for
improved varieties and and more plant
breeding investment for cover crops and
and
Farmers clearly want
more research to be conducted on
breeding and variety Improvement for
cover crops
and many also agreed that they would
grow more cover crops if they had better
varieties that were more regionally
adapted and some even agreed that they
would pay more for cover crops if they
provided more benefits for example
through improved varieties
so we we see that there's a demand and
and this these results in part motivated
the formation of this cover crop
breeding Network that
um that I am now leading out of Cornell
um so that this is a group that that
formed around 2015
um and and I
um got involved as a postdoc and now as
a faculty member so starting in in 2018
um and this is a network of
researchers at universities and at the
USDA both in ARs and nrcs as well as
farmer breeders
um and other stakeholders that are
involved in some way or another in
reading and Seed work in Agronomy
um and and
uh the idea with this network is is that
um we're we're improving uh multiple
different species
um to be
adapted better adapted to the needs of
of farmers across the country and and
we're doing breeding on Research
stations on farms and and also testing
these varieties that we're developing at
a wide range of sites across the U.S
um so we started out
um mostly focused in the Upper Midwest
and Northeast and have
expanded really across the country and
in our most recent site is it Alaska
that's a new addition this past year and
and we're working on a huge number of
species
um
with the main emphasis being on winter
annuals so these are
are species that are planted in the fall
and terminated in the spring so they're
they're filling that Niche between
um crop Harvest and a new crop being
planted very often in row crop systems
but but many of these species are also
used in vegetable systems and with other
with other cropping systems as well
um and we also have a big emphasis on on
legume cover crops
um we know especially with fertilizer
prices that that nitrogen fixation is a
really high priority for farmers and
um and especially in Northern regions
which I'll talk about in a minute we
often don't have a lot of legume options
that that can fit into our crop
rotations and and survive the winter
successfully
um
uh so so the emphasis again winter
annuals legumes
um but we also work on cereal rye and
and on some Brassica species as well
um
and the main breeding Focus that we have
uh or focuses are our high biomass
production we know that that more
biomass is generally correlated with
with greater provisioning of those those
ecosystem services that we care about
that cover crops are are providing we
also like cover crops that have good
early Vigor you know stuff that gets out
of the ground quickly and can compete
compete with weeds and and get a good
start before the onset of winter
winter hardiness especially at our
Northern locations
we also select on on flowering time
sometimes early and sometimes late
depending on the species and the
cropping system context that we're
thinking about
for our legumes we're also interested in
nitrogen fixation and then we have some
more species-specific traits that we're
looking at as well
um
and and so today I'm focused on on uh
the breeding needs for the northern U.S
as I showed on the map our Network
Foods researches across the country
developing varieties for lots of species
and a wide range of traits
um but but you know in in New York state
and some of the other Northern locations
in our Network we have some some more
specific needs a lot of it is focused on
winter survival
um so of course some farmers are are
interested in in cover crops that winter
kill for for some uh
um context that they're working in but
um we know that especially fall planted
cover crops are going to provide the
most benefits if they have the most
opportunity to put on biomass before the
next crop is planted so that often
involves surviving the winter and
growing again in the spring
so we approached this Challenge from a
wide
range of strategies and and so the rest
of my presentation will really be
focused on on how we're doing this in my
program and with some of our
collaborators at other Northern
locations
um so so we want more species that can
overwinter especially legumes and a lot
of our Northern sites Rye is really the
only cover crop option that's going to
survive the winter right now there are
some legumes that survive some of the
time but we don't have really good
consistent legume winter survivors
um and
uh we want these legumes because of
their ability to fix nitrogen and reduce
farmer input needs we also in general
know that that more diverse cover crop
mixtures uh have
provide more ecosystem Services than a
single species alone
so so we're looking for more options for
primaries and and in our Network we do a
lot of selection in the field
um in the fall each year we plan our
best material in multiple Northern
locations across the U.S and select uh
among the plants that survive and and
the main challenge with this method
uh is that Winters are unpredictable so
as breeders we love to see a field like
this one so this is a nursery that we
planted in the fall of 2016 on a farm in
Wisconsin
and we saw in the spring that that fewer
than 10 percent of the plants survived
and so we know that that we're really
only saving the seed of the most winter
hardy plants um and and that's great I'm
exactly what a breeder wants to see
um but for every selection environment
that looks like this one we have two to
three where either everything is
surviving or everything is dying and we
can't make good selections for winter
survival
so we deal with that challenge uh in a
couple of different ways so first we
plant many locations to maximize the
probability that we're going to have an
environment that looks like this one and
so so we have our breeding nurseries so
we have a nursery in in North Dakota and
Minnesota and Wisconsin and here in New
York so those are all have all been good
selection environments for winter
survival but we also do on-farm breeding
and so this is an effort led by Lisa
kissing pictured in the upper right so
she's a collaborator at the dairy forage
Research Institute at Madison Wisconsin
um and and so she leads this this
on-farm participatory breeding program
where we send uh see our best material
to Farmers
uh in in the Upper Midwest and they make
selections on their Farms
um
and and another way that we deal with
this is uh through controlled
environment testing so we have a
collaborator at the University of
Minnesota who who has done a lot of this
work previously
um and and so the goal here is is to
simulate winter conditions in a more
controlled way we can have more
predictable outcomes and we see that
that the results in the growth chamber
um in terms of the the
um the the material that can survive to
the lowest temperatures in the growth
chamber
um in this you can see that in the
bottom of the figure here so this
material survives to the lowest
temperatures
um and in the field
we see that that the same material is
also has the highest percent survival at
Cold locations
um and so this so this work is really
promising I think
um to allow us to have more predictable
and regular selection that's happening
um
and and I'm really excited that that
we're gonna be soon installing a a cold
temperature capable growth chamber at
Cornell as well so we'll be able to
expand this side of the the breeding
program here in New York soon
um so in addition to developing more
species that we can consistently
overwinter
um we also are interested in identifying
varieties that can tolerate later
planting and still overwinter and put on
biomass in the spring so so we know from
our agronomic literature that in general
the earlier you plant cover crops the
better outcomes you have in terms of
winter to survival and and biomass
production
um but you know we're interested to see
if there's within species variation if
there's some varieties that we can plant
later
and and still have good outcomes
and so one study we're looking at is in
Winter peas so this is work led by my
graduate student raksha tapa and she is
looking at the optimal uh winter pea
varieties and planting dates for winter
survival here in New York and also with
collaborators in Minnesota and North
Dakota so we're planting in uh in in
zones three to five and we're looking at
four different cultivars
um
uh and and for planting dates that fall
between late August and mid-october and
P is a really interesting case here uh
because so so in general what we've seen
especially with the legumes that we work
with is that earlier is is better
um in general
um and then a lot of the the
recommendations that we make to farmers
are to put it as early as you can but
with P it it looks a little different
there's a couple things that are
different about peas uh they have
they're able to to regrow from
from nodes below ground uh if if they're
planted deep enough so so even if the
above ground tissue is damaged or or
dies uh because of winter kill uh
potential if the peas are planted deep
enough and we recommend
um planting you know two or even three
or three inches deep
um for our Peak cover crops um then
then they can they can regrow and so uh
you know there's potentially a trade-off
uh if if they're planted too late maybe
they don't put on enough biomass and
don't do much in the spring but if
they're planted too early
um
they put on too much biomass and and
they expend a lot of energy
um
putting on biomass and and in the fall
and then all of that tissue above ground
dies especially if uh the the growth
habit can change
um so when they first start growing
they're they're growing low to the
ground but then eventually they start
growing vertically
um and so so those early planted peas
can can see a penalty as well
um and so we were interested to look at
this and see if there were a variety
differences basically and
um we have our our first year of data
now
um and so this is kind of hot off the
presses
um and
uh and we see some interesting patterns
here uh these are this is the the spring
biomass production
uh across the planting dates in New York
only
um and we see in general that this mid
to late September the intermediate
planting days produced the most biomass
in the spring
um
but
there was one variety here the icicle
that that produced fairly poor biomass
at all of the dates so just wasn't a
good producer in general
um but for the other varieties we saw we
saw improved performance that Shades two
and three
um but with this variety why winter we
see it really didn't it really suffered
from that earliest planting date
um and
but at the latest planting data it did
significantly better than it than its
counterparts so so maybe there's
potential here for this variety
um which was a fairly recent release
selected in Wyoming so selected in harsh
winter conditions maybe this variety
could be planted a little later and
still
um still produce adequately
and
um and we're doing some similar work in
in serial Rye this this project is not
we don't have data from this project yet
we just planted our first
uh our first year of of the experiment
this fall
um but the study locations are all in
New York state
um both here here in the Ithaca area and
also at
stations in Canton and Chazy so it's a
more Northern parts of the state with
with harsher winter conditions we also
have three on-farm locations
we're testing six varieties that have
been indicated to to be more winter
hardy than other material
um and we planted up to four planting
dates depending on the location all
between late September and early
November a rag can tolerate in general a
bit later planting than a lot of our
other species
and so
so it'll be really interesting to see
um if we have differences in in that
tolerance to late planting and which
varieties uh are best adapted to New
York in general we don't have a lot of
variety trial data
uncover crops in general so so stay stay
posted on on this one
uh we also for the first time this year
have a a couple of Serial ride reading
nurseries this is a fairly new species
for our Network
our nurseries this year are in in
Freeville in the Ithaca area and uh in
in St Paul Minnesota
and and with our nurseries we're also
evaluating like in the previous
experiment uh multiple planting dates uh
with the hope that we can identify some
some rye varieties that are are better
adapted to late planting
and in general we're selecting not only
for winter survival and and late
planting tolerance but in general for
early Vigor and biomass production and
and early maturity especially for for
Farmers interested in in uh no-till uh
production systems using roller cream
prairies we also have uh projects
related to illulopathy so a lot of
there's a lot of interest in cereal Rye
uh having you know ability to suppress
we'd see germination and growth and
we've we've had some really interesting
promising results on on that project
especially with collaborators in in
North Carolina who are pioneering that
work
[Music]
um
so in addition to looking at late
planting as a strategy to to mitigate
overwintering challenges
we're also looking at at varieties
developing varieties that can be
interceded earlier in the growing season
so the idea here is that
um rather than than waiting until crops
are taken off in the fall we intercede
the cover crops in in
early summer when the corn or or other
cash crop is is still small and the
cover crops can grow and establish and
then they kind of hang out Under The
Canopy of the cash crop for for you know
weeks or months and and this can be kind
of
um
yeah it can be a strategy that allows
you to to establish earlier and get
something in the ground that can can
then have enough you know energy and to
overwinter
um but it can be kind of a stressful
environment for the plant it's shaded it
doesn't have a lot of airflow there can
be issues with disease and and lack of
light and and other you know depending
on on moisture conditions you might have
um a competition for
for water right
um so so so a lot of cover crops are not
very well adapted to this environment
and so we're we're working to change
that so we've done two years of testing
we're in our second year of testing uh
red clover variety specifically for
interceding
uh red clover has been found to be more
tolerant than a lot of other species to
this system but but still performance is
a little inconsistent
so we evaluated 11 varieties and we
interceded
between rows of corn around the V6
growth stage which is kind of pushing it
to the the latest you would want to to
intercede uh according to the agronomic
literature
um that's kind of pushing it uh is as
stressful as possible for for the Clover
so we can can really evaluate how well
things do
um and
uh this is this is year one and two fall
biomass data so you can see
um but in year one we do have one
variety Mammoth that really performed uh
significantly worse than than many of
the other varieties we tested
um but but there's pretty wide variation
among the the top performers that so so
um
yeah so we don't have a really
consistent winner
um in in either year I'm in year two
which was a drier year we generally had
slightly lower biomass production across
the board and and uh this variety Alta
Swede in general uh performed worse than
the other varieties
um
and
uh in terms of spring biomass so we're
so we're still collecting year two data
um in 2023 but but in year one uh we
also saw significant differences in
biomass across varieties
uh in Spring and particularly a couple
of varieties out to Sweet again and
medium red
uh performed worse than a lot of the
other material
um so so again we don't have one clear
variety that's superior but we do have
some that are not uh that did not
perform well in interceding so that's
useful information for Growers and we're
also making selections now within the
the populations that had good survival
um where we we dug up plants from year
one
um and our
intermediating them in the greenhouse to
to develop uh cycles of selection to to
eventually have
um varieties of red clover that are
specifically adapted to interceding
and
uh and then I I wanted to talk you know
this is a seed conference and I've been
talking a lot about cover crops and and
breeding but I did want to mention some
of the work that we're doing that's
specifically focused on cover crop seeds
so so one big barrier particularly for
legume cover crop used is that the
legume seed is is fairly expensive
compared to Rye and some of the other
grass cover crops and so so especially
when these these cover crops are not
consistent in their ability to
overwinter and perform
um perform well and provide the benefits
that farmers are looking for they're
often hesitant to pay a lot for legumes
to you that if they're not confident
it's going to perform well on their farm
and so so
in all of our our nurseries we are
selecting in addition to biomass
production we're also looking at seed
yield and selecting our highest seed
yielding uh families but
uh we're specifically also looking at
Vegeta so Harry veg is one of the main
cover crops we're working on and it has
this seed pest vegetable kit that
um
has has kind of limited management
options especially when we're thinking
about organic Growers who are big cover
crop users in order to produce veg seed
there's multiple
um spray spraying events that need to
happen
to produce a good seed and avoid avoid
this pest issue so so the veg crooked
shows up in our field and it's
um really ubiquitous um of course we see
it in in the seed production regions in
in Oregon but but we see it here in New
York in our nurseries every year
um so it shows up at as early as
flowering and Google posits on the pods
the the green pods and
um
and then the the
larvae infest the
um the veg seed and and emerge their
um they have a an annual life cycle so
so they don't reinfest seed in the field
but
um but we often
we don't see the the
adult Brew kids emerging until after
seed Harvest and so often people don't
know that they have an infestation until
it's too late and and we we can see up
to 90 percent seed loss without uh
without any spray management
um and so this has really been a
devastating problem in our breeding
program uh you know over the first few
years before we knew that this was going
to be a problem we we had major seed
loss and very very little viable seed
from our breeding program and now we
have good Management systems but but it
remains an added expense for Growers and
reduces seed quality for those that are
not managing for it and so so we uh
starting in in uh about a year ago we
have been evaluating the hairy vetch
um our breeding lines and the USDA
collection for rootkid resistance and
and so that work is ongoing and um
we'll also keep you posted on results
for that but we're excited to see where
that goes I think it will have a big
impact on cover crop seed production
and
um I think that that's the the main
summary of the traits that I wanted to
focus on I don't I don't know that we
have time for questions or comments but
I'd love to hear from this group about
any other breeding targets that you see
would be useful my program is new and
growing and
um excited always to get feedback from
from stakeholders and other researchers
so so please reach out if you're if you
have ideas about what we should be
working on and I just like to
acknowledge the various people that
contributed to this work I the the whole
cover card reading network but
especially the collaborators I've listed
who contributed to the experiments that
I discussed today I'm also the the team
that I work with in Northern New York on
the the Rye variety trial my students
that have contributed to this these
projects the staff in my lab and
um and Farm staff who have supported
this work as well as the the various
funding agencies that have supported the
lab thank you very much for your
attention
any questions for Virginia while we have
her up here
all right Jenny there are no questions
it looks like
um thank you again for your presentation
it was really interesting to see what
you guys were doing down there at
Cornell uh with cover crops as they're
kind of growing here in New York and in
our region so with that that wraps up
our morning session here I think we have
a pretty good lunch planned so I will
hand it over to Alan and thank you to
all of the morning presenters those who
are still on Zoom we really appreciate
it I'm really pleased to to introduce
the next speaker
Molly uh most of us know from being at
past meetings as she was at when we were
at Club 86 in 2019 she was on the
program there and at that time she was
forming the CSO for ABM which has been
acquired by another company so the new
company called a rock scene and she's
the manager of the North American r d of
that
so the result of that merger there's now
two portfolios for now combined include
a yeast-based foliar and soil applied
bio nutrition and biocontrol products
along with Legacy ABM
seed treatment biotic products for the
large acreage crops so the focus of the
Geneva New York r d facility is on
supporting the rhizobia products and
formulation Improvement across product
lines Molly
well I really appreciate while this is
getting loaded I really appreciate being
invited back because last time I think I
forgot my presentation and caused major
glitches in the uh in the whole program
so
um
all right so uh I'm sharing I hope and
sorry about this uh bar here I don't
actually know how to get rid of that but
uh all right so again thank you for the
invitation and
um the nice introduction
uh
so
um obviously you can see my title we
work on Biologicals or microbial based
seed treatments and other products uh in
our facility and Bob Patrick is also
here he's a technician in the in the
group and together we
work on Innovation r d and trying to
develop new products for seed treatments
and foliar sprays all all based on
microbes so just this is a um just kind
of an organization of my talk uh the
introduction part I'll show you just a
couple of marketing slides in this just
to let you know a little bit about the
this company that has acquired us and
our functions and um it's actually
pretty interesting how we fit into the
market now but then
um as Ellen indicated we do a lot of
work on formulations and so talking
about compatibility with
um chemistries between the chemistries
and the microbes is a really important
part of what we do and is fundamental to
a lot of the the forward progress in
these types of products
so okay this is some marketing stuff
um so the um agroxine is the AG business
unit of Le staff East and the staff East
is an enormous company that specializes
in yeast they make Red Star Yeast
apparently one-third of all loaves of
bread baked in the world are made with
Le staff yeast so it's a big deal
um uh but but so because their focus is
yeast and yeast fermentation there are a
lot of outputs from what they create not
only the dried yeast that you might make
in the grocery store but also the
fermentation products and byproducts and
so the rest of these
um
oh well that's pretty small Okay so
uh the rest of these areas
um are also directly related to yeast
production so the baking is obvious uh
food taste and pleasure that Umami right
that's um what all these business units
ferment us you know the spider Springer
they're related to that fermentus is is
in uh fermentation as you might guess so
wine beer ciders
um uh a lot like what is done here and
at the at agritech
um the biotechnology areas
um and then and then down here in
healthcare we've got
um agroxine which is plant Healthcare uh
philio which is livestock Healthcare and
gnosis which is related to human health
care so we sit here in the agricene area
and like Alan said I'm the U.S r d
manager we also have r d operations in
bokuzay France
so our product line
um and some I'll talk about more about
this later when it comes to how you
might classify biological products
there's bio control biostimulants and
bio nutrition and so uh agroxine uh
brought the bio control and
biostimulation products to our combined
company and then the bio nutrition Parts
this is where um this is what our former
company brought to our total package and
I will discuss all of these more later
but
um I wanted to give you this background
because seed treatments are not you
don't generally think of yeast companies
when you think about biological seed
treatments or any type of seed treatment
um thinking about the companies that are
involved in this area I'm sure you've
all seen something like this before in
fact I probably showed this the last
time I was here that there are many many
chemical companies seed companies
biological companies that are involved
in seed treatments and um you know these
are some of the obvious examples and
also it shows how they've merged over
the years so this is a view from
uh
2009 maybe
um then a lot has happened since then
um the last time I was in here was 2019
and at that time the Dao and Dupont had
just um spun off their AG division into
corteva but in 2021 UPL United
phosphorus Labs which is the largest
company in India not the largest
phosphorus company but the largest
company in India UPL bought Arista and
they became the number five out of the
you know right after the big four and
then in 2022 Solvay purchased Bear's
seed coating business and yes that is
the Solvay that we talk about in
Syracuse the Solvay process it's the
same company also a French company but
all of these companies are chemical
companies
and so this is the mix that now
um my company is a yeast company is
playing in and the difference is that
these companies are primarily chemical
companies
that are used to working in ag and
lasaph and agroxine are yeast based and
r d companies that realize they have
something really good to offer to
Agriculture and Seed treatments so now I
want to change gears a little bit and
talk about the kinds of
products that we have I want to see I
can't really do that okay sorry I was
gonna try and move that bar again but so
um how we might classify
the different biological products oh
that would be great thank you okay
um how we might classify the the these
different products are base it can be
you can do it many ways it can be based
on the thank you so much on that on the
kind of organism
um that is the active ingredient but I'm
I'm going to classify them based on
function because this is how they're
regulated so first I want to talk about
bio nutrition and these types of
biological products
um
can and we're talking about C's here
applied to the seed applied to the soil
and then they work with either the
microbes that are already present in the
soil they work with nutrients that may
be in the soil and they uh help those
nutrients get into the plant or be more
bioavailable to the plant
so
um there's some pretty obvious examples
of those trichoderma bacillus
um are well known well documented for
their phosphate solubilization
rhizobia Brady rhizobium azos beryllium
these work to fix atmospheric nitrogen
so that the plant can actually take it
up and use it and rhizobium Brady
rhizobium these are our
um endophytes with the plant they those
are the organisms that create the
nodules on the roots
um and and in that way directly Supply
the plant with functional nitrogen
azosparillum is a free living
gram-negative bacterium that serves the
same purpose
um
but it it doesn't directly and the plant
isn't mainlining the results of of uh
azos beryllium function it um the the
roots need to interact a little bit more
closely
so
um so yes so this oh and this is a nice
picture of some nice big healthy uh
nodules on a soybean root so bio
nutrition products
um are used very commonly
um most
um most soybeans are either come
pre-treated or is very common to apply a
seed treatment of rhizobium or Brady
rhizobium to legumes that are planted
today
unless you have ground that that is
naturally rich in rhizobia
so that's just a good idea these types
of products are also
um not really regulated
um as much as other products uh
rhizobium Brady rhizobium these are
exempt from EPA regulation
ah sorry
okay another classification is
biostimulation
uh all the same microbes can be used for
biostimulation as our use for Bio
nutrition and other uses
um but this classification includes
those products that increase yields
they might
relieve abiotic stress abiotic stretches
like heat stress drought stress
um
and they can have effects on flowering
time or the resistance of flowers to
these abiotic stresses
um trichoderma bacillus these are are
well known to provide some kind of
drought resistance and um where agroxine
first started its work was on the East
and yeast fermentation products that
were shown to stimulate flowering so uh
flowering time is a little bit earlier
maybe you miss the heat of the summer so
um uh so that's one way that they can
work
um but but then um there and sorry these
organisms I'm giving are just examples
there are many more examples out there
so this is just a quick list
um other types of biostimulant uh uh
products might not be living organisms
um but maybe byproducts or or parts of
living organisms so um kaido sand is one
example
uh plant growth Regulators pgrs these
are usually chemical molecules maybe
derived from microbes that can affect
plant gene expression or might act as
plant hormones and so change how the
plants grow this is a regulated type of
product pgrs anything that shows this
type of stimulation if you make claims
of plant growth regulation the EPA does
regulate that
um and and there are many types of uses
the bio nutrition that classification is
mainly thinking about delivering
um nutrients from the soil you know
through the soil from the soil to the
plant uh biostimulation can be it can be
an application that is either on the
seed or also there are foliar sprays
that can also provide this kind of
benefit
and the third classification uh is
probably what this group is most
interested in is um bio controls
biological controls these are the the
microbes that control disease
so and and again I've I've provided a
very short list here there are many
others trichoderma uh can can provide
Disease Control by many mechanisms
sometimes trichoderma is a really
um vigorous uh uh soil inhabitant and so
it can out-compete other microbes and so
it just
um maybe pushes out or replaces um The
Bad actors in The Soil it can directly
parasitize other
fungi antibiosis is a mechanism by which
micro might produce literally an
antibiotic and so or a toxin that that
prevents the growth or or kind of pushes
down another
microbe and then there's also induction
of Defense uh host defense responses
um bacillus I think people probably know
BT very very well um basilister and
Genesis
um these bacillus generally speaking
produce some kind of toxin that then the
the insect pests would um ingest and it
causes death or extremely slow
metabolism and
um but there are other mechanisms not
just toxin they can also produce
antibiotics and induce changes in plant
gene expression
so um and and then the yeasts the kinds
of Products that come from my company
are are um generally inducing changes in
plant gene expression
um
obviously this is a regulated use of
these of these products these are
considered bio pesticides and
um they um
uh are used as seed and soil
applications but also foliar treatments
um and then so
um but for this conference um thinking
about the seed and soil applications
um yeah that is a main use and one
reason why this is so nice is if you
provide something that's a biological
control
on the seed or directly to the soil then
if you're relying on a mechanism where
competition or mycoparasitism or
something like this is important
the that beneficial microbe is right
there on the seed where it needs to be
when the seed germinates and and The
Roots start to grow and I would comment
this is also one difference between some
of the chemical treatments
um between chemical and biological
treatments is some of these biological
treatments can become endophytic and so
if they can establish their position on
the seed and in the root then they can
stay with the plant throughout the
season and provide longer benefits
okay so then
right
the next thing I want to talk about
um is compatibility
so
any seed treatment any treatment that's
applied in ag and you all know this has
to be compatible with everything else
that you're applying especially if
you're going to make some kind of tank
mix and so first seed treatments
obviously there is a tank mix and the
considerations are both physical and in
the case of of a biological control or
microbial product
um the biological component that
compatibility is really important
and if there is an issue with um the
biological compatibility that is a major
problem because it leads to shelf life
instability
um show the but the this is a little bit
different from chemical chemical
um uh shelf life issues
um
can be accounted for in the formulation
process
um and it's fairly straightforward
because it's a chemical process
but the biology is a little bit
different because you do have to account
for the Aging of the microbe over time
so thinking about chemistry
um the role of chemistry in any
formulation or in a biological
formulation we have to think about
um not only the active ingredient but
also the inert ingredients and I'll
describe this
um in the coming slides adjuvants
um these are in every in every chemical
product and every product really and
used in
um probably all tank mixes these are
sprezers dispersants anything to help
that mixing or help the efficacy of the
product in the end polymers colorants
are always present in C treatments
um and then thinking about the
co-applied
chemicals that might go into a tank mix
with a biological so
um it's important to note that
microbes aren't necessarily susceptible
to the active ingredients right the the
bigger issue most of the time is going
to be those inactive ingredients and
I'll explain that more in a bit
all right
so
all of us like to make analogies when
we're trying to understand things as a
vegetarian I generally think that salad
is a really nice thing to make an
analogy about so you get a nice healthy
delicious looking salad and what do you
want to put in on it salad dressing
right if you get a bottle like this
what's the first thing you're gonna do
you're gonna check the lid and you're
gonna shake it you're gonna shake it up
and then very quickly take the lid off
and pour it on your salad so that it
gets on your salad while it's all mixed
um so this is one of the biggest things
we have to think about when we think
about formulation because if we're
mixing uh different components in that
formulation
we have to think about how they interact
this is a good example of something that
doesn't really interact this surface
that surface layer right there nothing's
going on they can't blend the the other
effect that can happen is that you have
really good interaction or uh uh easy
interaction between those layers
and so then the other extreme is that
well you have good interactions between
those layers however bad things happen
right
um this is a picture of a tank mix where
where uh
different uh components to a tank mix
have been added and you can see all this
agglomeration things have precipitated
out and are floating or they're not
mixing well and so all of that that's
probably active ingredient that if you
were to spray this or apply it to the
seed it's not going to get on the seed
it won't get out onto your foliar spray
and it will probably plug something up
and that's bad
so
um so so a lot of what we do in our
facility is we think about what's
happening at this layer and so when it
comes to making it uh
mixing that layer it
um or making mixtures compatible with
each other so that they can produce a
good uniform solution or formulation
um we think about emulsifiers and not
just emulsifiers we think about the
general class of um of chemicals that
are surfactants so they are active at
the surface of of this of these layers
in between the layers and they can be
emulsifiers
um dispersants a lot of these things I
think you should be familiar with
because you think about how if you're
doing a foliar spray you need to be able
to wet and to spread the thing that
you're applying the same is true for
seed treatments during the application
process but also it's a fundamental part
of any liquid treatment because you're
needing to combine things that don't
necessarily want to combine
um
in the example of the salad dressing
well add a little mustard that works as
a really great
um emulsifier and you end up with this
delicious looking salad dressing totally
uniform and you can move on
so
um
but we have to think about as I said
before it's not necessarily the active
ingredients
that are causing the the
um that cause problems with microbial
based seed treatments it can be these
inactive and surfactants these
emulsifiers are things that can
definitely cause problems with microbes
so
um
uh just at the bottom of the screen here
I wanted to show you just a little bit
of demonstration
um that the uh microbes have membranes
and cell walls but this membrane we call
their lipid bilayer it has this
um uh structure you know with the the
heads and the tails that align to form
this kind of double layer and that's
something that can protect the contents
of the cell
um they the cell might choose to embed
some things in this like proteins or or
some poor molecules but surfactants
um can look a lot like the components of
a lipid bilayer and they can insert
themselves into cell membranes
and in in the worst case
they can tear holes in the pla in the
microbial cell membrane
and allow
toxins to get in sell contents to get
out and then you end up with something
like this where the whole cell contents
have leaked out and or the cell walls
have have
um uh kind of agglutinated together and
and it just makes a mess
um so that this is a tank mix
um uh demonstration or example
um but when we're working on a formula a
formulation for a microbial product it's
really important that we think about not
only the microbe that we are trying to
formulate but also about the chemicals
that I might be mixed with and not
necessarily the active ingredient but
the inactives right they have these huge
impacts on our formulations
um so when we make a microbial
formulation we have to have these
considerations in mind uh because you
know we want to have a uniform liquid we
want to make sure that you know from
liquid plays well with other chemicals
that it will be used with we also need
to make sure that we take care in how we
formulate the microbe so that we can
maintain that microbial viability for at
least a year
um uh if it's going to be used in a tank
mix and that's almost a certainty it
needs to survive in the tank mix with
other chemicals for several hours and
potentially several days if it's a seed
treatment the viability needs to the
viability of that microbe needs to have
some certain shelf life on the seed that
that could be it could be treated a
month before it's planted it could be
treated six months before it's planted
it just depends on the crop species
we're talking about
um and then
once you've planted it it needs to be
able to survive in the seed and soil
environment and also be able to wake up
and grow after having that dormancy
period
so
um these are some of the biggest things
that we think about as we're forming
Biologicals and and they are things that
as end users are also important for you
all or your customers to be thinking
about
um and I've just listed some things here
which I think should be either listed on
the label or or something to um that
that people should probably know
um doing a jar test to test for
compatibility will show you if you've
got that mess in the in the if that mess
in the tank might happen
um your supplier should be able to know
um if there are any special application
instructions manufacturers and this is
the last thing I'll say on this Slide
the the manufacturer of the product
itself should be able to give you very
good technical help when it comes to how
to make an application
um or let you know what the fail factors
are for the formulation for the
biological product
um but but in the end people who are
formulating and developing biological
seed treatments they are all working
towards being able to use biological
products just as you would a chemical
product
uh however there are certain parts about
biology that we just can't get around
and that biological membrane is one of
them
um all right so thinking about the
future and I'll try and go a little
faster I guess
um
so
um biological sea treatments um there
are more and more of them in the market
um as you could see from the slides
about all the companies previously there
are so many players in this game that
have a lot of brain power behind
developing these biological products
um they will be more and more of an
option
um and because a lot of them are
chemical companies we can expect that
the compatibilities between the
Biologicals and the chemistries should
become more and more common in place in
fact there are several examples of of
combined biological and chemical
products out there already
um the but there are we are seeing
changes in the field because of the
widespread adoption of biological or
micro based products and that is that
maybe 10 years ago it was a lot less
common for people to be using a microbe
on their Farm in their uh on their seeds
um and so more Farms were considered
virgin like if you hadn't ever used
rhizobia before
um you know then you would get an
initial burst of of
um a notable performance
but what we've seen as we've been
testing around the country over the year
is over the years is that when we test
on Farmer Fields because there's already
a lot of been a lot of addition of of
beneficial microbes the differences we
see between control and treatment
um are actually a little less and this
is a lesson for us about how we develop
now the environment that seed treatments
are going into now is not uh naive
um as it were that that there are plenty
of beneficial microbes and people are
taking really nice care of the soils
these days and so
um uh as we develop we need to think
about oh how do you get performance when
you are adding a seed treatment to an
environment that already has a lot of
beneficial microbes so it's just kind of
a change in thinking that is more recent
um uh thinking about regulatory aspects
the EPA is continuing to provide a lot
of guidance on both microbial and
chemical seed treatments
um
and this is good and bad
um however the um products that don't
necessarily require regulation
are more and more still needing to be
evaluated by EPA so some of the bio
nutrition products that I talked about
for example trichoderma trichoderma is
known to be a biological control it also
provides really nice bionutrition
benefits some of these dual uses are
going to be harder to do EPA wants to
look at all of these and make sure that
uh it you the if you're selling a
bionutrition product that you have
eliminated the possibility that it's
also a biological control
so um that that's a fairly recent change
that they are paying more attention to
these products
um
uh as we have already heard more and
more chemicals are being
um
more tightly regulated or even banned
this is true all over the world
um and and so it's really good news that
we're having more biological products
because we're going to need something to
replace the the active ingredients that
um are aren't um being
um so quickly registered anymore
so
um the last thing the thing I would
leave you with
um is a corn rootworm example so this is
a timeline and you can follow along
yourself and I have the reference there
at the bottom
um but you know insects are really
devious when it comes to evading pretty
much any control we throw at them
whether it's chemical or host genetics
um so
um there have been many controls put out
there for um this pathogen the corn
rootworm beetle yeah larvae and and over
the last many decades we have seen the
introduction of chemistries
the failure of chemistries the Banning
of chemistries even BT
which is biological in origin but for
which host crops have been um uh we have
we have transgenic or GMO host crops
with the BT toxin in them even this has
been overcome
and so um
the Biologicals need to be part of this
system and we do need to think about how
we deploy any of these Technologies this
is one of the worst case scenarios but
there are plenty of pathogens that um
can show this kind of pattern so
um it is a consideration as we develop
Biologicals and why we work with
chemical companies and um uh seed
treaters and everyone we can to provide
a holistic kind of or or a kind of group
think kind of product and process
so
that is all I have I think I don't I'm
like negative one in terms of time but
um if there are any questions questions
for Molly
yes sir why would it be a problem for a
product yeah
well it's not a problem actually but if
you are trying to release a product that
you want to be a bio nutrition product
but yet it also has can control disease
the EPA wants you to register it as a
biological control
so yeah so it's not it's not an issue
it's only an it's an it's an extra
regulatory step and the process for EPA
to make that determination is also a
pre-action so that's a minimum four
month process for EPA to say yes we want
to regulate it or no you're good to go
yeah Molly thank you very much
so we're going to switch gears and have
uh Margaret Smith give the undergraduate
Awards also as
I'm actually going to wait for like one
minute because I see all these people
fleeing the room in our undergraduate
award awardees deserve a good audience
so I'll let people get their coffee
stand up and stretch and in like one and
a half minutes we'll do our
undergraduate Awards
besides which Cassidy is leaving and
she's supposed to be up here
all right that that break was to get
coffee but it was also as usual to sort
out the technology so um thanks for
everybody for taking a little break here
um I'm Margaret Smith for those of you
who might not know me I sort of was a
backup assistant to Allen for trying to
organize the conference today but I also
get the most fun part which is to
recognize our um recipients of the New
York State agribusiness Association seed
committees undergraduate student award
so each year the seed Committee of
niceaba
identifies one or in some cases like
this year too undergraduate students who
have excelled in fields related to seed
and have career interests that somehow
tie into seed so I'm going to be making
these presentations jointly with Cassidy
she's sort of representing the
agribusiness side and also wearing her
hat as a former recipient of the
undergraduate award from the nice have a
seed committee so we have we had the
pleasure of having two awardees this
year I'm going to start with the one you
see on the screen because this is Avery
McLean she is currently in New York City
at the New York produce show they have
their trade show so she's exhibiting
today so she was not able to join us
um she is an advisee of Steve reiners
who's one of the vegetable researchers
here up at agritech and this is what
Steve had to say Avery is a senior Cal's
AG Sciences student and one of the
things she's doing is during her
undergraduate career she acquired a
small plot of land on Grindstone Island
which is up in the Thousand Islands and
she's converting it into a productive
small farm to provide fresh produce to
about a thousand summer inhabitants of
the island so you can see this is Avery
that's a little picture of her farm and
a description of her Farm she got a
small award from Cornell for oh shoot I
forget what it was called the um
I forget the name of the award it's a
small cash award to help students who
are doing projects related to Community
Support
um so Avery uh is working on this at the
same time as she's finishing her
undergraduate degree Steve said she's a
unique student that stands out from many
in her peer group he has never met a
harder worker she's been doing a heavy
load of class work a very intensive
schedule of classes that's allowing her
to graduate a semester early maintaining
good grades and at the same time
establishing this Farm up in the
Thousand Islands and Steve said she is
one of if not the best undergraduate
advisee he has met in his 28 years at
Cornell so that's impressive Avery sent
me this little quote so I will read it
usually I ask the student awardee to
come up and get their certificate and
their award and to say a few words about
their future plans so here's what Avery
said about her plans
in 2021 my partner and I started Red
Wing Farm a Market Garden on Grindstone
Island New York in the St Lawrence River
to learn about vegetable production to
create a community Gathering Place and
to increase availability of produce in
Jefferson County
my experience starting Red Wing Farm has
inspired me to pursue a masters in
Horticulture and a career in Cooperative
Extension to continue exploring
Innovative sustainable management
practices and share knowledge with the
local agricultural community so I'll say
congratulations to Avery let's all
Channel her sitting there in New York
City exhibiting her produce and give her
a round of applause
and I'll ask Alan to yeah to now we see
the smiling face of Alan Taylor because
our second recipient of the award is
somebody who is nominated by Alan Taylor
and Yoo Jang up here at agritech so I'd
like to call on Ethan Lewis come on
um Ethan is a senior he's at Hobart and
William Smith colleges here in Geneva he
has been on the Dean's List every
semester
um and he did a summer internship at
Cornell agritech right here working in
Alan Taylor's lab
um so that's what sort of led to this
nomination in the lab he studied seed
coding pelleting fillers and binders and
one of the things that I was told about
about Ethan is that he was a major in
Biochemistry not a bad thing for
somebody interested in seed and had
working experience in I.T services so
digital Technologies it's a really
powerful combination and the um the word
what what yujang had to say is that he
worked on developing new seat coding
materials that are edible with a high
resolution fluorescent Imaging system
that will allow for precision weed
management and Pest Management so that's
a really cool thing because he did such
a great job there he was offered a
casual hourly position continuing to
work with Alan Taylor which he is still
doing to this day Ethan I will say a
warm congratulations to you we have for
you also a nice certificate and more
importantly a small check
um in congratulations and I'll ask you
to say just a few words about your
future plans
foreign
thank you uh I didn't find out about
this until recently but it's such an
honor to be here with all of you today
and to receive this award
um I'm sure as a lot of you know and
what I'm going through right now is the
PHD application process most of which
were due today so that's been kind of my
life for the past couple weeks is um
applying for phds in toxicology and so
I'm interested in toxic molecular
toxicology as well as microbiome
toxicology studying the effects of
molecular mechanisms of toxins on humans
plants animals and also how microbiome
diversity relates and affects the
response of toxicity in host organisms
so thank you again for having me here
today I look forward to finishing my
time here in Geneva and also with Alan
and I wish you all a good conference
still
congratulations
okay uh we're gonna go back to our our
program we have two speakers both coming
in remotely I want to introduce Sam
kluto serves as a CEO at canner earth
science since 2007 Canada promotes ideal
agriculture by way of Innovations to
promote both desired yield and
environmental stewardship
while Sam was born and raised in South
Africa he immigrated the United States
in 1999 after graduating his master's
degree in accounting science once in the
U.S he worked in in banking real estate
and in 2007 started canner earth science
to live out a passion for sustainable
and renewable AG practices
today Canada has a portfolio of more
than 11 provisional and non-provisional
patents related to seed treatment bio
pesticides equipment for seed handling
and treatment we welcome Sam and his
research team where they'll provide an
overview of needs challenges and
opportunities related to Innovations in
agriculture and especially seed
treatment
so Sam will let you go ahead and take it
away from Georgia
well thank you and just a sound check
let me know that you can serve me okay
congratulations to the undergraduate
students Avery and Ethan
um it really is encouraging to
experience and see a generation of
individuals really passionate about
community and making a market Farm
available in their communities
so we
move here to our slides hopefully I hit
the buttons correctly
when do we consider the Innovations for
agriculture
isn't that a beautiful picture of a
light bulb just blowing out with all the
electricity well so it can be with
Innovations for agriculture and at
Canada earth science we experience the
complexity of Innovations just getting
increasingly challenging there are
additional layers of challenges
introduced by climate challenges but
also by Growers needs and
Growers understandings of what different
Technologies can do and a seemingly
endless appetite to combine different
Technologies to push that yield and that
genetic yield potential of seed further
and further up
if we consider an S equation of our
climate Smart Technologies we debated
that at Kenner quite a bit there are so
many definitions of not only climate
smart technology but also what
regenerative agriculture may be and we
say simple you know what if we can
increase our Readiness for unusual
weather patterns and climate patterns we
are doing well with climate Smart
Technologies and to that end we try to
find
avenues that will allow Growers
to enjoy one less pass on the field and
burn all the diesel and equipment or
with irrigation if they can limit the
center pivot irrigation system making
one round a growing season that's a lot
of water and energy saved and it could
contribute to climate Smart Technologies
expressing their value
um more on that you're in a little bit
should let you know that can or is is
inviting in Innovation from as many
sources as we can and we say when you
consider the production of food feed
fiber and fuel it really is amazing how
today we get close to that genetic yield
potential of seed but oftentimes it does
come at the expense of the environment
and the Very environment in which crops
are cultivated and as part of our four
air crop security program we invite in
innovation
that promotes both
the genetic yield potential being
achieved and at the same time improving
the environment
and that has been Kennards dry from the
proverbial day one back in 2007 when we
formed the company
and we find that a number of technical
expertise need to come together in one
area for that to truly manifest and come
to life
yield potential and environmental
stewardship and so
um not only is it seed applied
technology but also the on-farm
expertise so oftentimes we will work
with collaborators or innovators who
choose to team with us and find that
either one of these extremes may be very
well understood but oftentimes not the
combination thereof
and then um the Agronomy side is very
important organic chemistry and
increasingly the microbial
and plant-based Solutions are of value
to have as a subject matter expert in
your team
and out of the four F crop security
program we noticed that we we satisfy a
number of the Uno's sustainability goals
for 2013. we have them check boxed over
there we can make these slides available
to those who are of Interest
so what I look forward to sharing with
you here soon is the perspective from an
Innovative company
who are taking Technologies to Market
and who really have their uh boots on
the ground in the Farms doing the trial
work with Growers and hoping to bring
real solutions to real problems real
problems being
technologies that that may not work or
leave a grower frustrated without being
really scaled up well real solutions
being where we all sleep well at night
knowing that indeed our Technologies
offer stronger yield and environmental
stewardship
so it was coming a snapshot of some of
the camera technologies that may be in
different stages of the development
pipeline we're giving you a little bit
of a front row seat uh of what's
Happening behind the curtain here at
canar and our Innovations for the future
we're all familiar with different types
of seed Applied Technologies foam
treatment interesting and pelletizing
film treatment is hold the pesticides on
the seed
encrusting allows for a little bit of
weight gain and pelletizing usually a
round spherical shape allowing for
easier planting let's look at the some
of the film treatment recently in
peanuts
uh the picture on the far left is
peanuts applied with the first liquid
technology in the United States for more
than 20 years or as far back as we can
know peanuts have always been applied
with a dry material and it created some
challenges related to the flightiness
and the dustiness of the chemistry is
coming off of peanuts
the picture to the left you can see the
planability being improved by peanuts
with a good coating that allows for high
degree of slip of the seed that was a
monosun planter planting peanuts
and then when you consider crop
protection the third picture there of
also why we need sea treatments
crop protection protects the peanuts
against disease
and we'll talk about the canned saving
technology here in a little bit that
helps to overcome some of the phytotoxic
effects of pesticides on ceiling
but why do we need treated seeds crop
protection the number one goal Growers
will tell you they need crop protection
but there are some challenges in
treating seed
discussions earlier focused on the
biological challenges of seed treatment
but there just is a limited number of
fluid ounces that you can apply to any
hundred wait and see
and um uh usually with soybean customers
seldom do they want to go over five
fluid ounces per 100 weight some will
challenge eight maybe go to ten but it
gets to be a little bit of a nail-biting
experience for a lot of seed companies
going that high
other challenges of seed treatment
relates to uh pesticide toxicity the
pesticides are great at killing Target
pests but unfortunately as we all know
they also have a phytotoxic effect on
the seed and then over time resistance
can be developed to the very pesticides
that once protected the seeds buildup on
equipment is especially a big challenge
dust or dustiness
make a lot of uh headlines uh with
whenever something is Dusty and and
creating a
unwanted environmental impact flow
ability of seed regulation and again the
just sheer sophistication
of bringing a seed applied chemistry
package together is a challenge
and there are a number of Impossibles
and we run into this a surprising number
of times even just this week an
innovator came to us and spoke to him
yesterday and this innovator was trying
to get all the micronutrient demand of
the plant
as a seed applied technology
and uh that's my point number two so can
our takes the view that there are some
challenges and some goals in trying to
be climate smart but you just cannot put
on a seed all the amount of copper as an
example that you need for that crops uh
growing cycle the very copper that the
plant may need will unfortunately kill
off any desired
microbes that may be seed apply as an
example
another impossible the number one there
is we just cannot mitigate the drought
risk via seed treatment Alone by the
time you have enough water absorbency on
the seed the seed gets to be pretty big
and it just becomes commercially
non-viable
so what are some of the strong growing
areas that we see in
um
in in seed treatment it's definitely bio
control number one your insecticides
fungicides pneumaticides are globally in
high demand
followed by biofertilizers and
biostimulants
but surprisingly also we can talk about
all the wonders of climate smart seed
Applied Technologies but Growers also
tell us we just have a problem with
labor or we don't have enough water
whereas soil is completely uh destroyed
and we need that fixed before we can
invest in even climate smart seed
Applied Technologies some opportunities
however in the United States relate to
biopaste decides the United States is
the world's biggest market for Bio
pesticides probably a good 40 percent uh
interestingly followed by China and then
you have countries like
Argentina Brazil Spain Italy countries
follow but China United States is the
biggest biopest aside uh you know
innovator and user
but we see recently from companies like
pivot bio and and others the grant
positive nitrogen fixers and fertilizer
uptake agents and microbes huge market
and there's a lot of competition coming
in there
um but our biostimulants are seated by
Technologies uh even fertilizers and
awareness that we pick up pick up on as
the need to be micro plastic free and of
course ease of application liquid or dry
a lot of Technology seem to be geared
now not only for Upstream seed
application but also for uh Downstream
and even on-form applications a lot of
Technologies are making us way on Farm
driven predominantly by the lack of
shelf life of a microbe once the package
has been opened it's just not conducive
to up or Downstream seed application
and then uh performance matters
and we tongue-in-cheek say but also
appearance uh Innovation and the
complexity of innovation calls for once
the technology is applied to also
aesthetically look pleasing uh when you
look at the seed it's a it's an
experience that can or I don't think
will easily let go of we've often been
told look we just want performance
performance of the seed performance of
the yield we don't care what the seed
looks like no need to come later and
learn that no matter how good the
performance unless the seed looks
beautiful it's just not going to be work
it's just not going to work so
performance also really matters
some of the offerings from Canada that
we'll jump into here uh include our
broad spectrum
crop protection products uh our
microbial bio pesticide k357
and plant-based bio pesticides we'll
look at some bias stimulants seed
applied finishers and some equipment
so let's talk about the k357 patent
pending technology from canor we believe
it's a global first a single strain
broad spectrum bio pesticide
now we mentioned earlier that bio
insecticides and biofunicides are very
very in very high demand thirdly it
would be the nematocytes but an
increasing growth area
is a combination
mode of action where you both control
insectus insects and fungus or insect
fungus and nematodes there's high demand
for that combination type pesticide one
product multiple modes of actions
multiple types of of paste control
so we believe we have a global first
year in a single strain yet a very broad
spectrum biomatic side and the k357
bacillus like an informers
and it's uh it's capable of producing
secondary metabolites chitinase and
chitosanase which degrades the chitin
structure or the hydros skeleton of the
nematode
larva adult or even the the egg
and what we're seeing here is a picture
of a renaiform nematode egg which was
staying red being surrounded by this uh
bacillus species causing the XL2 lyse
going on and now I'm going to just show
you some data real quick here's an in
vitro assay to compare the efficacy of
the k357 against the chemical standard
evicta by syngenta
and four different species of
phytonicodes were were tested the root
knot sweeping cyst rediform and the
lesion imitones
and um before we went to field we saw
here that the k357
outperformed or matched the control of
the chemical romanticide
uh eurism University of Arkansas 2018
data that was shared with canar and this
graph compares the conventional
chemistries regarding nematode counts
um
55 days after emerges and at Harvest
and you can see how the cotton Harvest
with the k357 and two fluid ounces
is favorably higher compared to the
chemist chemistry standards
there's a really interesting slide this
graph here demonstrate the differences
of the the nematode counts differences
over the growing season comparing the
k357 biometric side against conventional
chemistries and you notice that the
nematode count drops and then goes
higher with your apamectin Chemistry
that's the solid line
however with a bio pneumatic side and
the nematode counts may not be as low at
first when compared to the standard
chemistries but continue however to
decline and then be even lower closer to
harvest
so I don't know if this is technically
correct language but it's it's kind of
interesting to see the proverbial
Factory in the soil and the and the knee
and the bacillus organisms able to
expand as the rhizosphere expands
um here we have a very interesting
development with a broad spectrum by we
have several broad spectrum bio
pesticides that address both fungi and
insects and we're a very technical
company and one of our products is as an
example called the yellow biobus design
just based on the color of the product
and then we attached very very nice lab
project names and numbers to that
but here we have a high standard
of making sure that our broad spectrum
biopesticides are indeed microbial or
plant-based and we wish to control a
number of pests
that are devastating to crops and we
have the standard that we only proceed
with a broad spectrum buyer pesticide
with known lack of toxicity to bees
avian Life Aquatic Life and mammals
and then of course it's a bonus if your
bio broad spectrum bio pesticide also
exhibits
biostimulant properties as an example
year of one of our Technologies you can
see the zone of inhibition by a
industry standard and by one of our
bio-based designs
uh this very chemistry uh with a zone of
innovation plates here were applied to
peanuts and that's on the next slide and
you can see how the performance of
conventional chemistry is enhanced
with a bio paste aside you see those
white spots circled in blue
that's the fungi on even chemically
treated peanuts
however when in combination with our
biopesticide formulation the efficacy of
the standard chemistry is enhanced so
that there is less of an opportunity for
pathogenic fungus to to establish the
same chemistry is we tested on nematodes
and we found on contact kill mode of of
nematodes here
and um the chart here shows different
types of nematodes lesion hematodes root
not nematode that just have 100
mortality when brought into contact of
our
experimental bio of pesticide
but not only do we see as an example
fungicidal control nematode control but
also King Worm or superworm control
and we see that on contact we have days
we're not going to go into detail on
this conversation about the mode of
action that's confidential to each of
these chemistries until we're further
along with certain patent filings but we
want to show you here real quick what
happens
I'm going to see if I can hit play to a
King worm that comes in contract with
our bio pesticide and it's a it's a it's
a
if you're if you're sentimental to a
King Worm this is a tough video to watch
but if you know how much damage they
cause to your crops it's an exciting
video to see that on contact the King
Worm uh dies so what happens here he uh
the Kingwood here takes it up it's in
gets in the system just enough to cause
death
and in no time the King Worm rolls over
and Jerks with the final throws of death
for us it's very exciting that a product
can kill a King Worm this large and also
control a broad spectrum of nematodes
and a broad spectrum of fungi
all this was in a matter of about 30
seconds
moving on to the next slide
foreign
let me see oh here we go no no going on
to the next site field trials but I
wanted to share with you we just started
getting field trials back some even as
recent as today so no chance yet to put
them in the slice but suffice to say
that the technology these some of these
buyers best decides that we've presented
here today about have produced
significant uh positive yield responses
this is all good if you have Disease
Control but unless you see it in
expressed in the yield positive yield
response no grower will pay for it and
so we've experienced more than 300
pounds lint per acre produced on carbon
where we've had this yellow bio
pesticide seed applied and we and on
other crops in other areas more than 14
percent
increase in Cotton yield
thanks to just this chemistry being
applied
in combination with current chemistries
so I do want to offer to the team here
if anyone would like to have these
slides even if augmented with our most
recent 2022 data feel free to reach out
to us and we'll be happy to make that
available to you
our micro 43j is a very very exciting
technology it's a seed applied small
inoculant microbial soil in ocular that
we apply on the seed
with two strands of bacillus valencies
and on the Petri dishes they can be hard
to see from far away you have different
morphology shown larger dots smaller
dots if you may and a dual strain is
expressed there and The Oxen production
there helps root elongation especially
at first that is helpful when the prop
gets established but it also assists
with five types of soil utilization
and and it also has some key leading
iron let's see what we've made the micro
43j look like when seed applied and
coming back to our important appearance
may be
so on the left you have corn seed and on
the right you have corn seed over
treated with micro 43j in one of our
slip shine type Technologies we're
coming back to how important appearance
is so now not only do you have a value
enhancement on the seed but also again
an appearance enhancement the slip shine
as the name suggests also AIDS slip to
the scene and shine in the appearance
in terms of data developed we we've done
a little had more time with the micro
43j than over more than 400 reps we saw
an average of four bushels an acre yield
increase by just applying the micro 43j
on corn there's a little bit of the root
structure that shows the benefit of The
Oxen with root elongation with micro 43j
is applied
and on soybeans with more than 200 reps
we see a 1.7 bushel and acre increase 70
consistent
the sway Roots there
a number of these Technologies are now
slip shine plus technology contains
micro 43j it's a little bit further
along managed to get registration in a
number of states so if you're in the
upper Northeast and you wish to apply
the micro 43j as part of your seed
treatment offering ask about the slip
shine plus 2050 the microbes are in
there and allows for Superior looking
seed with remarkable slip and flow
ability
going to talk about a POP so pop is our
plan to optimized performance or
pesticide overload protection
the problem that we have uh in the
market is that a number of pesticides
unfortunately while they protect the
crop they also are they also offer a
little bit of crop establishment drag
and the and the pop technology well not
yet commercially available offers to
overcome that phytotoxic drag to the
seed treated with pot
and we look forward to this year also
test the pop technology for overcoming
phytotoxic effects of any foliarly
applied
fungicides the herbicides or even
insecticides
the a picture is worth a thousand words
and so you see on the far left in the
far left tray corn seed doing really
well it's the control almost
disease-free environment no pesticides
but the middle the middle tray of corn
seed is at 2x chemistry and you can
clearly see the stunting in the
germination an early figure of the Sea
on the far right while it's still 2x Kim
we have one of our pop uh
Renditions in combination as a seed
treatment and you can see to what what a
stunning degree the phytotoxic effect of
the chemistry is overcome by part
the the uh what we have here is a sweet
these are soybeans
and you can see how the untreated
control is doing fairly well
with the chemistry even at One X is
applied the soybean growth has stunted
slightly
and even with a little bit of pop at
half X and then at One X the soybean
does remarkably well so we believe pop
will be a very very well received crop
establishment tool
um here we have soybeans in the
greenhouse and you can see how they do
much better how the leaves open up and
the growth is stronger when the
chemistry is applied as a seed treatment
in combination with pop
here we have peanuts peanuts do carry
quite a heavy dose of fungicides to
protect them
and with peanuts you want them out of
the ground ground so fast like most
crops but peanuts do well when they lap
as fast as possible and there's no dirt
between the peanuts and so we believe
the pop will go a long way to promoting
lacking of the peanuts
you can see the difference of of the
peanuts when Pop is applied as a seed
treatment
uh some more pictures here just shows
different types of Pop Bob 2 Bob 3 we've
we learned that we have different uh
variations of our underlying key
components and pop four different seeds
and you can just clearly see the value
here of
um
off top the very compared the very
bottom with a second from the top two x
chemistries and even with two x
chemistries and pop three you do very
very well even better than one X
chemistry unseen
so about 10 9 300 it's a you know coming
back to
where technology is applied and k93
offers to
um offers to Growers the opportunity to
apply technology on Farm
and the year is a number of experiments
with different
can Technologies at the very bottom is
without any of the can technology you
can clearly see on Cotton
how
how tough the the chemistries can be on
seat cartoon is often applied with over
40 fluid ounces per 100 weight of
chemistries easily two insecticides and
four or five different fungicides in
addition to talc and pH neutralizers
effect of corn here I'm going to pick up
a little bit of speed for the sake of
time
we've done some germination tray root
essays uh
uh and we're watching the root length at
day six you can see that there is a
statistical difference on corn with
um
109300 applied in addition to the
Insecticide Fungicide package checked
also the shoot length
next picture shows uh swabing again with
different Renditions of can can a 200 to
9300 so 9200 works well on core 9300
works well on Suite going on to can save
and this product is this technology is
commercially available
and registered in Most states we have
essential amino acids here and chelated
iron and it's a very very versatile uh
fertilizer and applied as a seed
treatment it it
promotes crop establishment and when
applied foliarly it it helps the plant
to allocate extra photosynthetic energy
that the canned saving provides to where
it's most needed quick picture here
shows soybeans without and with canned
salmon applied it even one fluid ounce
per 100 weight
can save it on Peanuts very similar to
the pop pictures this shows purely the
the
biostimulant effect of gas seven the
fertilizers the states where it's
registered
and we're going to briefly talk about
slip shine Molly where you're Molly
deficient uh or your soils pH coal for
money we apply slip shine Molly directly
on the seat
so you have an enjoy absolute placement
of the molybdenum on the seed allowing
your Growers to apply any inoculant
infuro I don't know that we can stand
behind this claim but I will just share
with any seed treat as NEC Twitter that
we see increased comfort and Adoption of
applying inoculant on the seed alongside
the slipshine Lolly we won't be able to
say that your inoculants are safe when
applied with slipshine morning we're not
a inoculant major but we just see
increased adoption of both inoculin and
slipshine Molly on the seat at the same
time
members the other states with a
sub-shine lolly as registered for sale
the slip shine line of Technology carry
dry plant when the CD is tacky neither
wet nor dry and delivers that slip shine
and steam Sheen and in the case of flip
shine plus it delivers the microbe 43j
also
equipment uh I'm sorry we're we're
running really late here on on on the
presentation and I I hope that people
could follow up with you at a later time
if muscles
sure thing
so I wanted and introduce the last two
speakers uh from from germains and I
know both really well Dale krolakowski
started his career in the research and
development of pharmaceutical projects
and then moved into agriculture in 2009
and building the r d department and
built r d department for germains
currently overseas disinfection of
seed-borne pathogens priming developing
novel seed pellets in new pesticide
protection for soil-borne pathogens
uh also with him is Hank Hill Hank
received his PhD at the University of
Florida and then he actually spent a lab
one year in my lab as a postdoc back in
the 80s he's then been out in the
California seed industry ever since
working at a number of different
interesting crops and vegetable flour in
rangeland restoration for the past 35
years
so I introduced both and we're going to
go right into their presentation at Sea
technology enhancement beyond the
genetics
Alan
for attending today
um Hank and I are going to tag team a
little bit on this presentation so bear
with us as we get through it
um we're taking a a different tact this
is really about
um trying to educate the audience a
little bit about the seed treatment and
Seed technology
um if you want to know more about
Germaine's products in specific you can
come to our website or or reach out to
Hank and I later on
so Germaine's just a little bit overview
um started in Los Angeles in the 1900s
we used to go across the street to this
oyster house and have some oysters and
beer after work but um you could see our
our company is right across the street
Germaine seed technology
so pretty exciting that we've been in
business since um around 1918 I believe
150 years of experience
in the 1950s is when we first created
the sorry the first pellets
and are focused on the sugar beet
industry
we were then purchased in the 1990s by
Associated British foods and that's who
our our owner is today that's a
multi-billion dollar family-owned food
company compare them to craft Foods or
something like that and we were
rebranded as germane technology in 2010.
um we talk about a lot of the basic seed
Technologies
um Sam presented a whole bunch of
different Technologies himself and I
heard him speak a little bit about some
of these in general we're going to get
into a little detail about them
ourselves
disinfection of course is is around
removing seedborne pathogens we like to
follow disinfection with seed Health
making sure that um we're combining
nutrients or Biologicals to improve seed
growth and development
see priming Hank is going to go into
detail about seed priming and how that
works
I'll come back around and talk about
seed pelleting and film coating and
pesticide applications
what's the beauty of seed technology is
that you can stack different things
together
so we can prime seed we can remove
seedborne pathogens we can then put it
in a pellet to help it for mechanical
plantability we can add pesticides on
the exterior or insecticides to prevent
soil porn pests or other pests from
attacking the plant
so um it's it's pretty important for
most Growers to have a combination of
Technologies especially on the vegetable
side which is primarily the the market
that Germaine's drives
seed health and Seed disinfection can be
both organic and conventional processes
um the the goal is to try to not only
eradicate the surface pathogens but
really more importantly to get down into
the subsurpose seedborn pathogens it's
pretty easy as you you would guess to
surface sterilize a seed especially a
melon or something like that that's got
a smooth seed coat it's the deeply
rooted pathogens that are are the
different ones to tackle
um the the real goal is to provide seed
that's not going to come down
um and transfer any disease to the plant
or transfer pathogens into the soil
there are a lot of obstacles in
obtaining clean seed
eradicating those funguses are much more
difficult than bacterial pathogens and
those that live underneath the seed coat
or the pericarp are are very difficult
to to
eradicate without damaging the seed as
you would guess
one of the other big obstacles around
obtaining clean feet is the assays and
the testing there's a lot of good
technology around removing pathogens and
then there's really good technology
about detecting pathogens on seed
through PCR and different techniques
like that and that that makes a lot of
issues with phytosanitary movement of
seed internationally where where
somebody believes they've treated seed
and has a a negative test result and
then an importing country will test the
seed through a different method
Hank are you there yeps I'm here can you
hear me oh can you hear me get up
because
Dale's else connection dropped with us
okay listen I'm just gonna go to my part
right now because time is of the essence
here
he'll he'll join us back later at the
end
uh anyway uh thank uh we I want to thank
you guys for allowing us to participate
in this conference
so with with no further Ado I'm going to
talk about seed priming and of course
this has been around for a long time uh
the best definition that I can come up
with is that it's a controlled hydration
for a specific time period
at a Pacific moisture content followed
priming uh it's simply controlled
hydration for a specific time period
followed by dehydration resulting in
better seed lot performance and this is
an idealized idea of what it looks like
here
let's see if I can okay
why did we Prime seed well of course
priming uh primarily results in Faster
germination and field emergence
uh because when seeds are primed the
germination is kind of kick-started
some processes have been uh some
processes have just been started others
have been completed a lot of times time
to germination could be cut in half and
then field emergence is more uniform
because germination is more synchronized
and I'll give you an example of this
here we have an idealized laboratory
germination at 20 degrees centigrade
please note that the prime seed
germinates first a little bit before the
non-prime but more importantly the rate
of germination is uh is is steeper and
because of that you could get more
synchronized germination like for
instance in this
uh in 10 hours 25 to 75 percent of the
seed is germinated whereas for the
non-prime seed it's closer to 16 hours
the second and most important reason why
we Prime seeds and this is really
important for for a lot of our leafy
greens is that Prime seeds uh prevents
dormancy priming allows seeds to
germinate at higher temperatures than
they normally couldn't and allow seeds
to germinate without light when they
normally wouldn't and I'll give you an
example of that here's Prime to
non-prime lettuce seeds the lettuce
seeds on your left are primed the
lettuce seeds on you on your right were
not or it's I guess it's reversed but
anyway the uh yeah the lettuce seeds on
your right are not and that's because
the environment has induced dormancy you
put these seeds back into a optimal
environment and eventually they'll all
germinate although emergence will be
more erratic
in this graph we show
in this graph we show
um
that priming
allows seeds to germinate over a wider
range of temperatures than non-prime
leader seeds and also it uh seed seeds
maintain their viability even in the
dark whereas non-prime seeds they lose
their dormancy is imposed as the
temperature increases
and it's worse in the dark
so it's what I call the um
it's what I call the uh double whammy
okay I'd like to talk about priming
processes
uh osmotic priming gets its name
gets its name
because seeds are placed in a solution
that osmotically regulates their
moisture content
okay seed moisture content is high
enough for metabolism to occur but not
germination
you know seeds need oxygen to Prime just
as they need oxygen to germinate so a
constant replenishment of air is
necessary in this method because the
solution only holds
so much available oxygen
in both hydro and solid Matrix priming a
measured amount of water is applied to
prevent germination in Hydro water is
supplied directly to the seeds
and in solid Matrix water is applied to
a mixture of seeds and beneficial
materials
and in both instances because seats are
rotating in a vessel with plenty of air
aeration owning beat only needs to be
done periodically
since priming is a process several
variables influence optimal response
among them of course is length of time
uh moisture content while priming and
then of course the priming temperature
for the most part
you can see that
too little priming results and
sub-optimal responses and too much
priming results
in a substandard product
for example this celery variety
the seeds of which were primed at three
different temperatures for the same
amount of time and then germinated
in the light and in the dark at 25
degrees Centigrade
uh the control the non-prime control is
enlisted here because uh none of No No
Seeds not none of the seeds germinated
in the light or the dark at 25 degrees
Centigrade evidently this celery variety
is very sensitive
right now you can see how different uh
priming at different temperatures
influence the expression
uh of of germination and so you really
kind of have to pick your poison and
just come up with the best overall uh
priming protocol
there are limitations to seed priming
the first and most important limitation
and this is something that I was not
aware of when I was working in Al's lab
is that priming not all the time is
economically feasible
it it adds an extra crop extra expense
to crop production
and so you got to make sure that the
benefits outweigh the cost trialing is
important and initial testing is usually
done at a no charge to make sure
everybody's going to be happy
priming works best on high quality seeds
and unfortunately priming shortened
shelf life
Germaine's collects its shelf life data
on all priming protocols that we
developed
and overall we found that the priming
response is good for six to 12 months
for most crops
some crops like onion can uh can have a
shelf life of less than three months uh
shelf life of three months but we want
to make sure that our customers know
this and that uh when they when when the
seat does come in they got to go ahead
and plant it
my last point about priming is that
priming accelerates the rate of
germination but not sealing seedling
growth however as shown in this slide
faster germination causes seedling
growth and photosynthesis to start
earlier which can have a profound effect
if time is an issue this happens of
course in Greenhouse celery and this is
really one of the most dramatic uh
uh most dramatic examples of uh how
speed of germination affects
uh how speed of germination affects uh
subsequent crop growth
I want to make a quickly talk about uh
seed quality
you know I've talked about how important
it is prior to priming
but uh maintaining seed quality
after uh
priming and germination is important too
so what I want to do is is talk about
shelf life
over time all seeds lose Vigor and
viability
you know I'm sure you've heard you know
the rate of loss is dependent on the
seed booster content and the storage
temperature and I have alluded before
Prime seeds lose viability faster than
non-prime seeds
uh the reason for for uh the reason is
that priming causes seeds to be more
sensitive to moisture content than
non-prime seeds and now Taylor and I
worked on an experiment and only took us
nine years to publish this but I want to
give you an example how why seed
moisture is so important
viability loss this illustrates
viability loss when seeds are rapidly
aged
and
primed and non-prime seeds were put in
two different environments one
environment
was a high moisture content environment
seeds were were uh were were stored at
nine percent and at 38 degrees
Centigrade the other environment was a
low moisture environment low seed
moisture content environment but it had
a higher temperature please note that
for non-prime seeds in either
environment the rate of uh viability
losses is is exactly the same
but for Prime seeds
seeds stored at a slightly add nine
percent moisture content basically lost
their viability in half the time that
seed's restored at six percent
so moisture content during storage is
extremely important and we make all our
customers aware of that
I'm going to briefly talk about seed
pelity
you know there's two ways to pellet seed
one is most most of the most of the
pelotine is done in what we call a
vertical plant pan it's
um
and uh the other uh
equipment used for pelleting is
um is a rotary pan uh normally rotary
pans are used for film coating and
encrustment and not for pelleting but
you can pellet seeds in a rotary pan
anyway this is an example of uh what the
seeds look like while they're going
through the rotary pan and being
um coated with material
Okay so
why do we pellet seeds
you know pelleting was initially
developed to improve plant spacing in
the field
for example because of the small seed
size lettuce was always solid seeded and
the only way to thin to one plant per
foot was to use a short-handled hole
for obvious reasons the use of the
short-handled hoe was outlawed in the
state of California in the mid 70s
so a way was needed
to space plant the seeds in the field
many schemes were tried
but the use of the Stan hay planter was
adopted be because it did the best job
of spacing out the seeds the only
problem was that the seeds either had to
be round or pelleted
oops
oh here we go sorry
please note the holes in this belt
pellets or round seeds drop into the
holes in this belt the distance between
the different holes is going to
determine the the distance between the
seedlings in the field
and this is a cross-section of what the
planter looks like you can see the
rotating belt goes around and drops the
seed out at a specific distance uh the
vegetable the pelleted seeds are held in
the hopper
and this is what uh what happens you can
see that the pellets are nicely
cingulated
uh in this case it's every two inches
and because they're singulated and
spaced out you can go ahead and thin the
plants out with a long handle though
and So currently this is probably the
the method used by most Growers but we
have uh have further modernized this
process there is
um a company that has a automated
thinner the automated thinner uh goes
ahead and using and using cameras and
nitrogen fertilizer to kill The Unwanted
seedlings uh you can get your your
plants uh space planted
you can get your one plant per foot
uh what I'd like to do now is talk about
film coating and pesticide application
uh we do quite a bit of this at
Germaine's uh there's many different
reasons for doing this
here are some of the applications you
apply fungicides and plant insecticides
you you coat the seeds with fungicides
or insecticides and you you put a film
coating over it to uh protect the
workers and to make sure your pesticides
stay on the seed and in the ground
instead of the air
foreign
film coating seeds has benefits to for
the grower we're looking at film coating
with both vegetables and and acronomic
crops
film coating film seeds are are brightly
colored and you can and this can be used
to differentiate what what uh what is
exactly being planted so there's no no
mistakes for example you can film coat
the red uh the onions red for onion
varieties that are red
and of course pesticides can be applied
to the seeds and then sealed to protect
loss
the interesting thing about this is that
with these more aggressive pesticides a
lot of times the seed has got to be
pelleted before the pesticide is applied
to the pellet and then it's film coated
to keep the pesticide on the pellet
that is my last slide
I want to thank everybody for listening
and do we have any time for questions
yeah Hank I'll go ahead and open up any
questions from the audience you want me
to turn on my camera
yeah sure if you want we we want to see
what you look like after being at Geneva
Cornell agrotech now well you know from
almost 40 years ago yeah I know let me
see if I can get this done here
um Dale Dale's also uh rejoined us now
okay uh Dale do you want me to shut down
my part and then you can continue
we're just we had two glitches this
afternoon we've kind of run out of run
out of time so I really just want to
open it up for from questions right now
can you see me no
but it's a it's a beautiful row of trees
though okay there we are back into the
trees I'm sorry back in the trees are we
in Europe where are we at we're in
Ireland
okay uh Sam with counter here with the
question can you speak a little bit
about the degree of germination loss on
Prime seed does it come to a point where
it's quickly commercial the non-viable
to any longer Prime the seed can you
just speak to that a little bit well
this has always been the issue and the
issue with seed at Prime seed aging
isn't as bad as it was when I first
started working in this industry uh the
use of computers uh to control inventory
has really improved and so a lot of
times uh you know like the automobile
industry uh orders come in and uh their
their processed right away and sent to
the to the grower in an on time
situation for the most part as I said
before Prime seed that that the seed
that we Prime commonly lasts for uh six
months to a year I don't want because
we're working with a lot of different
species I hate to generalize or hate to
be more uh specific than that
so Sam I'll jump in a little bit there
you know there are minimum
specifications for incoming raw seed
and as long as the minimum specs The
Germ specs are in place there's usually
not an issue I mean you might see one or
two percentage Point drops in germ on
some species and some Lots specific Lots
but um it's not it's not normal if
you're priming seed and you see a five
or seven or eight percent drop in
germination it's it's probably not uh
the priming method as much as it's the
raw seed quality
yeah that's the other point that Dale
brought up that's important the higher
the quality of the seed lot the better
the the uh storability but a lot of
times over the years we've experienced
uh Growers that want this one variety
this one seed lot and they just want and
they don't care if the viability is 75
they want to get it planted so that they
can
um
in in in increase the amount of seed
that they have of this variety so it's a
varietal increase
okay any any other questions
good I really want to I'm sorry to kind
of push this thing through but uh we
really kind of run overtime here this
afternoon I want to thank all this
afternoon speakers uh and everybody that
contributed to the success of the seed
conference for those of you that are
receiving the dec credits hey Hank
um they're on as you go out in the back
table your certificate with your name up
do not pick up your neighbor's
certificate pick up your own I've had
problems with this before that's why I'm
emphasizing it uh pick up your name on
the certificate and have a great uh trip
back and thank you very much for
attending the seed conference
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu